all right what's up
YouTube Rumble Facebook wherever you may
be watching this
thank you for being here and welcome as
always I see the chat's getting pretty
Lively right now
hope you guys are ready for tonight I
know that I am this is a stream that has
been long in the making
um this brother was supposed to come on
some months ago and some things just
came up that
kept that from happening but now here we
are and the time is upon us so I am
looking forward to it he's going to
predominantly be doing the talking
tonight so that's always nice like I
like to tell you guys uh it's always a
benefit when you don't have to hear me
so hopefully
um you will be blessed by what he has to
share tonight one thing I will say is
that his camera will be off if you're
familiar with his YouTube channel the
mystery man himself has not revealed his
identity and he has his own reasons for
that and so that's perfectly fine but
that is okay because this brother went
through a lot of work for tonight in
preparing a uh presentation that I was
like whoa I did not anticipate
um this level of preparation Etc so you
guys are in for a treat but before I
bring him in folks
we get a lot of comments a lot of you
comment on the videos asking questions
folks use this little search bar up top
on our website answeringadmonism.com
use this website
this website is our gift to you the
viewer The Listener whether you're an
Adventist atheist Christian Buddhist
whatever you're going to use the site we
want you to be able to browse and
navigate with ease you can come on here
I just linked somebody earlier they were
asking is there somewhere that lists all
of Ellen White's contradictions type in
contradict
folks you can go and search to your
heart's desire
and you will find
lots of contradictions you can use this
little search bar up top for all sorts
of things you can type in specific
questions you can type in names of
individuals I mean
you can use this to your heart's content
it's only going to populate 10 options
for you in the search bar but you can
just click the little magnifying glass
or hit enter and it'll take you to a
page just like this and it will populate
everything we have you can navigate from
the sidebar and go by topic all of the
videos are also hosted on here by
category so you can come on and simply
browse these by topic and click and
voila the video will also populate for
you but again these question and answers
go by category let's say diet and health
was Daniel a vegetarian you can read
about how Ellen White claimed that meat
never passed the lips of Daniel and yet
that's not true at all because Daniel
was a faithful Jew who would have
partaken of the Passover Lamb but
nevertheless any Scripture you can just
hover over it it's going to populate for
you but anything that you see that's
hyperlinked like this it's going to take
you right to the source
everything that's hyperlinked will
function and operate that way so you can
scroll through to your heart's desire
again
oh she said whatever contradicts God's
word we can be sure proceeds from Satan
yep there it is right after she
contradicts God's word ironically enough
but nevertheless this website is our
gift to you please utilize it you can
come here you can access all these
resources you can go to the wallet memes
you can partner with us you can donate
you can access our other our social
media platforms which we just launched
our Instagram page this week so please
go and check that out if Instagram is
your fancy because we're now on
Instagram so
with all that said let's bring in
tonight's guest like I said the floor
will predominantly be his I will only be
chipping in or chiming in rather
periodically so with that said brother
test the profit thank you so much for
being here the floor will be your sir in
just one second
as I switch us over here and get your
slides brought up the floor is yours
hey miles thanks for having me on are
you able to hear me okay yeah we can
hear you perfectly fine you've got no
clipping going on and uh sounds good
all right
so I thought a while about what to share
this evening
um I considered your mixed audience and
then decided to focus on her grandiose
claims and how they tie in with her
literary habits rather than just showing
example after example
I also decided that before starting the
main presentation tonight
I would take about 15 minutes to share a
brief background on how I came to
discover the gospel and question our
prophets Ellen White
I was born into a happy Adventist home
we attended one of the major SDA
churches in our large metropolitan area
of several million people
and the church was even visited by some
of the SDA celebrities
at the church Ellen White was respected
mostly by everyone
and her health reform views were
following
it wasn't an offshoot by any stretch of
the imagination
some of the earliest memories as a kid
were participated in Daniel and
Revelation seminars at our church
these seminars seem to always start at
Twilight and I remember they allowed me
to hold this gigantic flashlight at a
young age and I would direct traffic
coming into the large parking area
I felt amazing as a young boy
and I would that I had a place in the
remnant by helping people Park
I would then go inside to hand out
pamphlets and those Bibles with the
large hourglasses on them I don't know
if you ever remember these
oh yeah then I sat yeah
they're they're legendary hardcover
glossy finish
yes
then I sat down to listen to the
presentation on the soon Sunday law and
apocalypse
the end of the world was always around
just right around the corner and I was
routinely reminded I would probably
never make it to college get married or
have kids
it was frequently discussed in our
church that this Pope this president or
this new law enacted would be the last
one
and then it would be the end times
but early on I began to observe some
inconsistencies with how Ellen White was
utilized in the church
I noticed that some families abided by
her counsels closely
While others met her halfway
and others just plain ignored her
I noticed how Ellen was used to flesh
out parts of scripture where there was
little detail
and all were fascinated by these new
insights or details into scripture that
the remnant was solely granted access to
I mean what other church was blessed to
have her conflict of the ages book
series or her testimonies for the
remnant Church
what if the church was given a diet to
follow to prepare their bodies for the
second coming
so as a kid when I observed other
Adventists ignore Ellen White and treat
her like a tabloid writer or someone who
is of no significance it really puzzled
me
because they never explained why they
didn't believe in her gift
they just didn't
that observation persisted and troubled
me and at times I would ask myself how
do I know if she was a true prophet
I attended Adventist schooling
through eighth grade and then my parents
reluctantly sent me to a non-sda
Christian High School as there wasn't an
Adventist High School in the area
and it was here that I had my first
exposure to other Bible believers
and I I noticed they did not seem
unintelligent or wanting to live in sin
as rumor had it
because as you know we were taught that
these Christians were Babylon that they
had adopted Pagan or papal practices and
had corrupted Christianity
so it was surreal to finally sit with
these Heretics in their church and
listen to their sermons
I remember my first day there the the
teachers were aware that I was in SDA
because you had to write it on the
application
and they sat me down and they said
so you're a Seventh-Day Adventist
it was asked in a way that was
respectful but I could felt they felt
sorry for me
of course inside I was thinking if if
only they knew the truth
I attended weekly Chapel at this school
with sermons typically on the Christian
walk and grace through faith
and I noticed that there was much more
happiness and Assurance in Christ at
this Chapel
in contrast to what seemed like every
third sermon being on getting ready for
the end of the world or keeping the
Commandments at my local SDA Church
it seemed to me these Christians were
already ready
in fact I remember a notable sermon one
day on the gospel
I was probably 14 at the time and after
the sermon I remember I walked out of
the sanctuary
and looked up into the sky and thought
am I saved can I have Assurance of
Salvation right now
am I already ready
but then I thought well how can I
possibly know if I'm saved if an
investigation into the Deeds of
Christians began in heaven in 1844 and I
don't know where I am in the queue
you know either Christ's blood has
atoned for our sins already or it hasn't
and I need to get ready
as Ellen wrote each had a each has a
case pending at the bar of God
I was aware of those terrifying words
Ellen White wrote in the great
controversy regarding facing your life's
record
as a Christian where your unforsaken
sins would be recalled by God and then
later by others who wanted to see why
you didn't make it to heaven
for example Ellen wrote in the great
controversy
sins that have not been repented of or
forsaken will not be pardoned and
blotted out of the books of record but
will stand to witness against The Sinner
in the day of God
so I would think
have I repented of every sin have I
forsaken them and now only commit
nuisins
what happens if I commit the same sin
twice
if I keep doing the same sin over and
over again will the Holy Spirit Lead Me
all right Ellen White wrote that we must
overcome our sins for them to be
forgiven
so lamenting on this as a teenager
caused the idea of assurance I heard in
that school Chapel to vanish away
because it seemed presumptuous that I
could know my destiny now
especially when there was no way of
knowing when your ticket would come up
in the Heavenly Rolodex
besides Ellen wrote Our acts our words
even our most secret motives all have
their weight
all have their weight in deciding our
destiny for real or woe
though they may be forgotten by us they
will
bear their testimony to justify or
condemn
and Miles as a teenager I had all kinds
of Acts and words I was ashamed of
I knew at that time there was no way I
was going to pass an investigation or my
acts words and secret motives had their
weight in deciding my destiny
so there was this juxtaposition of
learning of a Finnish atonement for my
sins at that Christian High School
and then in Adventist media sermons in
Ellen White I would hear the opposite or
a mixed message
of a righteousness that was entitled to
me by accepting the provisions of the
gospel and through obedience to the law
this created a war within my soul
because even though I would decry
legalism
I realized I could not be saved if for
example I didn't keep the Sabbath
this was grounded in the Adventist
culture
for example Ellen our Prophet wrote to
the youth in 1853 that if quote those
who wish to be blessed and approved of
the Lord in this world and who expect to
finally be saved and have right to the
Tree of Life must keep the Sabbath holy
so in light of what I heard at school I
wondered if Ellen was wrong
maybe she wasn't who she claimed to be
but no that can't be it
we're the last they run the church with
the spirit of Prophecy to guide us
how could she be wrong
at least that was the presupposition
held by us children at church
a test one thing I think I want to share
with the audience just so they're on
board
um folks he has spent all sorts of money
buying primary source documentation so
the images used tonight are images he
has taken he's not resulting or
resorting to screenshots or the online
library he's photographing actual Source
materials I just wanted to share that
because I think that's important for
people to know
yeah for most of it there's a few slides
that are from the Adventist Digital
Library
um so we were taught that uh we were
lucky that our profit received Heaven
Sent warnings such as the health message
in my home and in many Adventist homes
we had fake coffee fake meat fake
mayonnaise fake cheese
in order to satisfy those alleged sinful
Cravings without causing physical ruin
because of course Ellen wrote that the
real versions of those Foods We crave
would destroy our body and cause
impaired intellect
in councils on diet and Foods she's
recording right she's recorded writing
flesh Meats butter cheese Rich pastry
spice foods and condiments are freely
partaken of by both old and young
these things do their work in deranging
the stomach exciting the nerves and
feebling the intellect
so at one point I began to wonder as a
kid why God would give the last
generation before the apocalypse a new
diet
wasn't he going to make us a new anyways
in reflecting I found that there was
such a contrast between the two worlds
of that so-called apostate Christian
School and traditional adventism in
Ellen White
foreign
things we learned from a young age is
why we are supposed to respect Ellen
White's writings
my parents frequently read through the
official 27 fundamental beliefs book
from 1988
you know the yellow one published by the
church
this was the Edition owned in my home
and in this book it Is Well known that
it was reinforced at the beginning of
chapter 17 on the gift of Prophecy
that Ellen White is the Lord's messenger
her gift is an identifying Mark of the
remnant church and that her writings are
a continuing and authoritative source of
Truth
so since my family took the teachings
and publications of the Adventist Church
seriously
my parents believe that statement and
taught me the same
reading of Ellen White was encouraged as
it brought new light into the great
controversy conflict between Christ and
Satan Health recreational activities and
other topics
in my home my father a deacon in the
church read Ellen White in the Bible
consistently
now that I think about it he was
probably following the recommended
Readings By The GC or the church
quarterly which he read often
but all the prophetesses major works
such as the conflict of the ages series
steps to Christ counsels on dieting
foods testimonies for the church and the
many compilations of the white estate
were always lying around
so I would pick them up and read them
we also had amazing facts and Adventist
satellite programming playing in our
home often with Stephen Bohr Dwight
Nelson Danny Shelton and others
there was a general Buzz of excitement
in my parents when I was young
because we were part of the remnant God
was coming soon and we needed to get
ready
for those who are listening that were
not raised in adventism
you have to understand the story that
was taught to us through Adventist media
church and schooling and that was that
our prophetess Ellen was special
she was unlike other little girls
the premise was that she was frail and
injured by a trap by a childhood trauma
to the face
but miraculously through divine
intervention instead of dying she
recovered and God's glory was manifested
by her display of Supernatural strength
and abilities
we were taught that she didn't breathe
during her alleged Visions because only
God gives breath
and that she wrote at length about
subjects she should not have known or
understood because of her lack of
Education
it was because of those reasons that we
should believe she was special and the
mark that we were in The Remnant Church
and that was why we did believe in her
without questioning those young kids
because that was a great story
besides those magnificent visual
descriptions of how the young sickly
girl transformed into the powerful
Oracle of inflammation
the church would also discuss their
biblical proofs of a prophet to support
her
with her favorite being that she spoke
according to the law into the testimony
so she must have lightened her
so after high school I attended an
Adventist University for several years
these were some of the best years of my
life as for most people University is
fun
during my time there I reread many of
Ellen's major works as it was part of
the University curriculum and you had to
actually sign a note that stated you had
read The Prophet's book assigned in the
syllabus
and this was one test you did not want
to lie about
I noticed that most students there
respected her but many would pick and
choose what they wanted to believe from
her writings
to be honest in the classes on Ellen
White and the history of how adventism
was started
when I looked around the room what I saw
was that most of the students were
absolutely bored to death there was no
relevance
even though they respected Ellen and
knew her ideas my classmates seemed more
excited to eat lunch then hear another
lecture on how to understand Ellen White
the professor tried his best to
entertain the class with enthusiasm and
discussion but I took notice that he
seemed to be the only one excited
miles I'm curious since you engaged in
discussion at the Adventist University
you attended what was your experience
that the students there seem interested
or excited about Ellen White and having
his history or did you find mostly
apathy
um it was most definitely apathy but I
will say there was typically a spectrum
um you had people who if they were into
adventism they tended to be all in now
some of this is going to be uh
demographic based due to the location
and proximity of the SDA University that
I attended but nevertheless it tended to
either be all in gung-ho and they wanted
to like really understand and really
know it's not to say that there weren't
people who were uh somewhat like nominal
just because it's like this is what we
do because this is how I've been raised
and we just this is what we do
um but I was an art major and the art
Department was uh where all the closeted
atheists and agnostics were
um who outwardly openly uh went through
all the Motions
um but when you talked with them behind
the scenes
um it was well I don't actually even
believe any of this this is this is all
nonsense I'm just doing this because my
grandparents said if I came here they'd
pay for my schooling or that type of
thing so it was it was kind of a mix and
I was talking to people
um all across campus I mean this is when
I first had left adventism and I was
just trying to basically sharpen my
sword so to speak
um getting experience evangelizing and
doing apologetics kind of one-on-one
with people and so I talked with
hundreds of students
um and that tended to be my experience
yeah yeah it's interesting you bring up
atheism because one of the most
impactful events during University and
in my life as a whole came one summer
evening between College semesters when
my roommate and I went out to play
tennis
while we were running around the court
he informed me that he no longer was an
Adventist and was now an atheist
I was shocked so we stopped playing ball
and talked for a while uh talked for a
while Around the Net
the next day feeling I had to say
something to defend my faith in the
church I focused on Ellen White's gift
basically repeating what I heard as an
Adventist kid for example the physical
manifestations the early Pioneers wrote
about how correct she was in her health
ideas and how it seemed we were headed
for a Sunday law
he's trying to give all the evidence I
could muster at the time
you know basically asking him how do you
explain all of that
he was not amused and scolded me for
believing such nonsense
and so again rattled and realizing I was
getting nowhere with him when defending
Ellen or adventism
I decided to dive in and learn the
historical Arguments for Christianity
that I had never thought to read before
in hopes I could find something to help
him change his mind
I remember for the rest of that summer
when my roommate and I would climb into
our bunk bed he would lay on the top
bunk and read Nietzsche out loud to me
while I tried to fall asleep below
let me tell you miles Nietzsche and
nihilism does not make for good bedtime
stories
I gathered as much yeah
my roommate was constantly reminding me
how pointless life was how there was no
purpose to anything and of course how
wrong Ellen was
but even though I began to wonder how I
knew Ellen was a true prophet I let
those thoughts slide as confronting them
was too overwhelming
I continued to believe she was a
messenger of God and had a credible
story
I figured my friend just wanted to live
in sin
but that summer flipped a switch in my
mind
and created within me a strong desire to
learn the fundamentals of Christianity
so I began to read outside of Adventist
Publications listen to non-avonus
Christians who listened to debates and I
even attended a debate with the late
Christopher Hitchens
sometime during this period I discovered
Timothy Keller and with his sermons and
books I found a more profound rich and
beautiful Christianity than I had ever
experienced in adventism
salvation for the first time seemed
obtainable and the cross not as a first
step to atone from my sins but as an end
to my sin
I saw Christianity not obsessed with
getting ready for the second coming and
an invisible investigation into the
lives of Christians in outer space
but rather one resting in the finished
work of Christ on the cross
this new form of Christianity I was
discovering was pulling me in
it seemed
so different from the anxious culture of
adventism wherein many are unable to
rest
there many Adventists are aware they are
on probation and that the second phase
of Christ's atonement is still in
progress
they're also aware that there are many
instructions that Ellen White has
provided that they should follow
her mission was to prepare a people to
stand in the day of the Lord after all
so I began to wonder if what Keller was
preaching on the gospel the law and
human nature was true
could Ellen or adventism be wrong
was that possible
could my friends or family be wrong
about this
I started wondering if there was more to
this story than I learned in my Decades
of adventism
but unfortunately again those thoughts
faded away as we all know questioning
Ellen is not simple
who would want to doubt one of God's
Messengers who brings us light from the
throne
I know some Avenues will argue that they
don't need Ellen because they have the
Bible
they easily dismiss any scrutiny into
her life because they claim they don't
need or care about her
or they diminish her status to some lady
who wrote some nice books
but in there lies the conundrum right
the Adventist Church will teach on one
side that Ellen is optional
that she's only pointing to the Bible
but if you question her story what
happens
suddenly her optional status vanishes
and she becomes one of the most
important pillars of their faith
the way I see it though is that if you
cannot have adventism without Ellen
White
and you can't as she's the identifying
Mark of the remnant Church
and she's not simply a woman pointing
you to the Bible she is much much more
so I continued living as an SDA with
conflicting views of salvation
until the year that changed everything
for a lot of people
2020.
as you know with the pandemic the church
is closed down and for the first time in
my life I was not going to be greeted by
happy Sabbath as I walked into an
Adventist Church the next Saturday
and so when Saturday came I felt a void
and in this void these repressed
questions on salvation Ellen White began
to surface
so I finally decided to make an
appointment to speak with a semi-retired
Adventist Pastor who is a friend of a
friend to clear up these questions
and the first question I had was on
salvation
when you think about it the most longing
question for any human being on this
planet
is how do I continue to spend time with
my loved ones
and for the Christian it is expanded to
how do I spend eternity with the one who
created me
I figured the other Christians in my
high school and my workplace were just
blessed to be unaware of the
investigative judgment where Christ
would review the sins of Christians and
discard those Christians that did not
pass its quote searching scrutiny
so I sat down on the pastor's couch in
his office one evening reflecting on
what I had learned from Timothy Keller
and I looked him in the eye and I asked
have I just misunderstood knowing if I
will make it to heaven
I thought in my head how did this happen
with all the Decades of sermons I heard
in church thousands of hours of
Adventist programming and all the
Sabbath School discussions that I had
attended
miles if there was one important message
that should have been beaten into my
head throughout all those years it
should have been the gospel that by
faith alone I was already reconciled to
God and had eternal life
and yet that was absent
instead where I had caught glimpses of
this reconciliation was from that
apostate Christian High School and
within the sermons of Timothy Keller
so in talking with the pastor I
naturally brought up the investigative
judgment as the reason I believed I
couldn't have assurance
I knew I was wretched and that the
recording Angel was just as busy writing
down my faults in the Great Book as I
was in repenting of them every night
before bed
I was trying my best but I never felt I
was good enough
you know at one at what moment can you
feel you have done enough that you could
relax through the second phase of the
atonement
pastor's expression informed me that he
hadn't expected me to bring up the
investigative judgment because again
this is 2020 and that Doctrine is not as
overtly taught as much anymore
even though it is still the core pillar
of adventism
he then to my he then to my surprise
shared with me the issues that he had
with the doctrine
he said he was doing his part to push a
more gospel-centered message in his
sermons
and that other Adventist pastors were
starting to do the same
as I said on his couch he told me
stories of other Adventist members who
had come to him and some who had
actually physically hurt themselves in
preparation for the Lake of Fire because
they knew they wouldn't pass a
scrutinizing investigation
so they wanted to build a tolerance for
the upcoming pain
I know that's an extreme example but
these were the stories he heard
that Pastor understood the horrific
implications and logical conclusion that
Doctrine causes many to reach because he
heard them disclose firsthand
these weren't former Adventists on the
internet these were real warm-blooded
Souls who had sat just where I had on
his couch and confessed their dread
knowing their sinful nature
but in contrast that evening
the pastor shared with me the gospel the
good news that Christ has already atoned
for all of our sins and has reconciled
us to God through faith alone and his
finished work on the cross
we are now his sons and daughters and
have eternal life
the atonement is complete
we don't have to worry about the second
coming or what the pope is doing
he spoke about how our works have
nothing to do with our Salvation
including the Ten Commandments
and that it is solely dependent on
Christ
we probably spoke with each other for
two hours that night
and it was life-changing
this pastor in two hours had surpassed
Decades of sermons and Sabbath School
discussions
but in order to provide me this good
news he had to wiggle around this core
belief in adventism
that Jesus is reviewing Christian sins
in a book somewhere to determine if he's
going to keep them or not
and to be honest the doctrine of the
investigative judgment felt to me like
heaven was trying to figure out all they
could to keep me off the books to keep
me out of heaven
it was like a weed out course you'd take
in college Only the Strong the most
faithful to the Ten Commandments survive
and are accepted into heaven with open
arms
miles what are your thoughts is this
representative of your time in adventism
and those you have witnessed to
yeah depending on kind of like you
mentioned there's been this bigger push
I would say it really started like its
seeds were
stronger or they've obviously grown over
time but the seeds of this sort of like
modern day what you're mentioning the
modern day Evangelical flavor of
adventism that's you know we're just uh
we're just another Protestant Branch
like you brother that thing started in
like the 90s to be more prominent which
is when I was being like raised in the
Adventist Church so it kind of depended
obviously who you were talking to and
where you were going but right the
majority is what you're describing like
when when you'll get these s modern sdas
that want to tell you no no it's a big
tent it's a big tent brother we're we're
Christians just like you
um you're completely out of step with
literally all of the official Source
documentation
exactly so what what you're presenting
it's like when I went on the seeking
what they saw a podcast what these three
Adventist pastors it's like well
gentlemen you're trying to figure out
what an Adventist is in this series and
you're kind of trying to put out this
image of like oh see adventism is this
sort of like malaise of just like an
ethereal we don't even really know it's
this mystery type thing where it's like
no dude that's like the exact opposite
of what it is it's like we know for sure
what we are we're the one true church
this is the pillar of truth I mean it's
over and over again it's in the review
and Herald she's saying this the
investigative judgment is one of the old
landmarks of truth that they are to
never shift off of so
um in terms of the people that actually
understand Seventh-Day adventism the
Adventists that actually understand
these things the people you some of the
people you were mentioning earlier
obviously some of these big name
teachers they understand how
foundational this is to the system they
understand it is an it's not this grab
bag where you can just like
why I reject that this a la carte style
adventism it doesn't work that way all
this stuff is connected and so with
those types of individuals which I would
argue is the majority absolutely what
you are saying is 100 correct
yeah
so after discussing salvation
um it dawned on me that I I still hadn't
investigated Ellen White's claims
and now that covet was making room in my
schedule
I figured it was time to look into Ellen
as I have mentioned before I had
questions throughout the years left
unanswered
but how does one question their
spiritual Grandmother who claimed to
have received light from heaven and now
sold books to provide this precious
light
from a child I just accepted her gift
thinking that there was no way the
church my family my community and the
professors I looked up to at my
Adventist University could be wrong
but I was curious if there was
information I wasn't aware of
I had perused the Adventist Book Center
before
but what if there were other books
written on Ellen White not sold there
it dawned on me that any organization
could select what information should be
shared to the masses and what should
require more digging
and this is certainly not unique to the
Adventist Church of course all major
organizations do this
it doesn't have to be a conspiracy it
can simply be that unknowingly biased
individuals get together in an
organization and say we have tackled the
issues delay members do not need to know
our best men have been on it
let's not kick up dust for no reason
you know it's like going into a
bookstore of a political party
and expecting to find a book that calls
into question their party's presidential
candidate it's not going to happen
instead what you find are books
supporting that specific individual
with this realization I figured I should
see what others have written just out of
curiosity
to be clear my aim was never to leave
Ellen or adventism
I wasn't trying to find evidence to
prove her wrong
rather I figured if Ellen was a true
Prophet she would withstand scrutiny and
I could somehow Salvage her with my new
understanding of the Gospel
but what I hadn't anticipated
was just how much information was out
there
if one dared to look
so I returned to the pastor and I told
him that while I believed in Ellen White
excuse me and wanted to know what
evidence there was that supported her
claims
I also wanted to read something that was
not published by the Adventist
publishing companies so that I could see
if there was any information that had
been left off the table in Sabbath
School
that evening the pastor mentioned
several books probably five to seven in
total that I could read on Ellen from a
different perspective
but the only one I could remember when I
arrived home was the white lie because
of that perfect title
written by an Adventist Pastor from
California
so I went on Amazon
and looked up the white lie but held off
on purchase purchasing it for a few days
I felt I was cheating on God that I was
doubting his messenger
I felt a shame for even considering to
look into Ellen from a different
perspective because I knew she claimed
people would fall away from her
and I didn't want to fulfill that
prediction
a thought came to me that maybe the
devil was using this book to deceive
Adventists
so those of you who are out there who
are interested in studying the subject
of Ellen White
I understand your trepidation
I've been there and I understand the
struggle that arises when you begin to
look into her her claims
and I would bet miles has probably been
there too
I have the book on screen on the Shelf
uh right back there
so
yep
eventually I just I developed the
courage and purchased the book
the irony is that it arrived the next
Sabbath and after I pulled it out of the
mailbox I remember walking back to my
house and thinking
what have I done can I read this on the
Sabbath
if drinking tea is a sin then certainly
reading this book must be a sin
well
five years later I mean five minutes
later
curiosity got the better of me and I
plopped on the sofa opened the package
and began reading
about an hour later my wife walks by
sees me reading the white lie with its
iconic creepy cover
and asks what are you reading
now I wasn't sure what to say at this
point as I just started reading and she
wasn't aware that I was talking to the
pastor about Ellen
but I mentioned it was a book on Ellen
White and
apparently she had passed off ideas from
other authors as from God or
have you heard of this
she said no and she didn't tell me at
first but she began to worry and pray
for me because her heaven was reading a
book her husband was reading a book
questioning the spirit of Prophecy
as I read the book I found the material
interesting and thought provoking
I was bringing issues to the table
such as the source of her information
that I had never heard or even thought
to consider
you know why would you think Ellen was
using other authors material when she
makes such grandiose assertions claims
little education has Visions in front of
eyewitnesses and then tells avenues that
God wants them to buy her books
one would that idea ever cross your mind
unless you were exposed to the evidence
I'm aware that there is a generation of
Avengers who are aware of Walter Ray's
book that documented and accused The
Ellen White of plagiarism
but not every generation is
and not everyone in the previous
generations were aware either
I've heard of individuals in their 70s
who are just now learning of this issue
after watching my series and are now
tossing Ellen aside
so why are even the previous generations
hit by this issue
could it be that there is a universal
understanding of how Ellen became an
author and how she wrote her books
I think so
perhaps this Universal understanding has
been allowed to persist because it makes
her story all the more intriguing
and this is why Ray wrote his book with
the tone that he did
he saw the writing on the wall because
he knew how Ellen's story was told
he knew how Ellen was marketed even if
genuinely to the members
so I read about three-fourths of the
white lie and then set it aside and I
began collecting some of the books
mentioned to look through them myself
I was intrigued by the subject and
during this time I came into contact
with other researchers who had also
studied this topic similar to Rey but
also beyond what he and his graduate
assistant discovered
they shared their research with me and I
began to see Ellen very differently
I could now entertain the possibility
that the story of the prolific sickly
girl who received Divine insights with a
meager education
could have been fabricated or
exaggerated
it was like a candle was lit in a dark
cellar
and suddenly I could step in and
actually consider an alternative
Viewpoint without jumping to some
preconceived conclusion
or cliched response to defend Ellen
White
there was something here that I felt
needed to be studied
during this time I also began to read
what the Adventist Church had written to
defend her so that I could see a
balanced picture
but honestly after reviewing the
research I had already compiled I did
not find their arguments to be very
convincing although some are more
developed than others
I should mention I'm very much looking
forward to discussing their arguments at
a later date
but for me there is an order to things
and a lot of the SDA arguments in my
opinion thrive on the members not being
aware of the examples
for instance if you come across this
issue and read about it on the white
estate or some other Pro Ellen White
website
it will typically give you very few if
any examples
and the ones they do give are usually
the weakest of examples
by this method one could argue that
they're able to stifle curious Adventist
Minds before the whole debate is
considered by waving their hand with
appeals to Authority such as the ramek
report
but I get it they're going to defend
their prophet and do what they feel is
necessary to keep her reputation strong
among the members
so one of my goals is to give more of
the evidence and then visit their
arguments and let people decide for
themselves
in reading about this subject one of the
realizations
that baffled me miles
was how this issue has been discussed
within adventism but is also hidden in
plain sight
what I mean is that your average SDA
will likely not be aware of this issue
of her sources unless they were around
and interested during the numbers in Ray
controversy of the 1970s and 80s
or unless they're interested in SDA
apologetics
or perhaps a theology major with a
source a short section
in their syllabus on Ellen White issues
or when someone like me sits down to
look at what the books not sold in the
Adventist Book centers have said
when I was very young this was a big
topic because it was spreading around
the church because of the res because of
the release of numbers and raise books
it's true responses and debates were
written about the subject
but then it disappeared for a new
generation
so here I was moving throughout the
Adventist school system through graduate
school and yet I was hearing about it
for the first time on my couch reading
the white lie in 2020.
I asked my mother who was in her 70s if
she was aware of the plagiarism debate
she said she knew about it but decided
not to tell me as a child because the
church hired a copyright attorney and
thus there was no problem
even though she admitted she never
looked at the evidence herself
it was that easy for her a quick appeal
to Authority and the subject was closed
forever
I wonder how many other Adventist
parents to decide decided to withhold
the issues of the 1970s and 80s because
they felt their children didn't need to
know
to be clear I'm not claiming it was a
grand conspiracy by our parents to hide
the information
but clearly they knew the implications
of telling a child these issues
and thought it better to avoid giving us
that information so that we remain
faithful followers of Ellen
and I would argue adventism in a way
does the same with its members
but has material ready for when they
come knocking
I know the SDA apologists will become
agitated with that statement claiming
that the issue has been addressed over
and over again
yeah as I said it has been debated and
written about but the discussion is
mostly within their circles or possibly
at the Seminary level
my point is how many sdas sitting in the
pews today know of these issues and have
actually seen the evidence I doubt very
many
as someone who has raised in adventism I
see it this way
if I may use an analogy
when you are preparing for surgery you
meet with a surgeon and he will discuss
the pros and cons of the surgery
perhaps the pros that you will have less
pain or the surgery could save your life
but the con may be that during surgery
you may have a stroke a heart attack a
hemorrhage or even death
and while the analogy may not be perfect
without knowing the issues that have
plagued the adventism in Ellen White
just as one may be ignorant of the risks
with the surgery
an informed decision cannot be made
just think about it even if we take Rey
out of the equation
how many members younger than 45 are
aware of Glacier View Desmond Ford and
the Monumental implications of that
discussion
what about the impact of profits of
Health on Alan's health message
again in my experience I would argue
that outside of the SDA history and
apologetic enthusiasts who make up a
very small piece of the Adventist
landscape the average SCA going to
church every Sabbath driving their kids
to Pathfinders eating fake meat and
tuning into SDA media on occasion are
unfamiliar with these topics
in short I believe most Avenues are
blissfully unaware or apathetic
I'm curious though miles you have
mentioned or you had mentioned at
another time that you have been engaging
in discussions with Avenues over the
past decade especially at the University
level
did you witness that demographic show
familiarity with these issues or was
there a general ignorance so the topics
of the 70s and 80s
no there was a general ignorance
um I will say at the time
you know it wasn't these things that
actually led me out of adventism so I
know a lot of formers it was well like
again another book I have on the Shelf
back there uh Desmond Ford's Daniel 8 14
the day of atonement in the
investigative judgment I wasn't familiar
with these materials until later on into
the future
however I was aware of
um say that the passing over top like
the the skimmed over version from
hearing people like Dale ratzleff so I
was aware at that level I just wasn't
able to say discuss it on a sort of
highbrow level to really poke or prod to
kind of see where people were at though
I will say
kind of back to the question you were
asking earlier
um
for the most part the people that I knew
that were super heavy into adventism
this is not what they were super into
they may have been super into the
Theology and really studying like I want
to know the 28 fundamental beliefs and I
want to know why I believe what I
believe Etc but when it came to to stuff
like this I was typically pointing to
Ellen's own writings or the writings of
the Pioneers so I was a lot more
familiar with the air the erroneous
things within say James White's writings
Uriah Smith Ellen White herself Etc and
whenever I would poke uh anyone on those
sorts of things I would get the response
that I think a lot of us got whether it
was from students professors you know I
I talked with all sorts of people men
religion professors pastors lay members
students
um the response was kind of universal it
was uh well we don't really need to go
there
and that kind of tells you the answer to
your question that
um the the vast the the broader category
of dealing with anyone whether it's Ford
rat's laugh numbers Ray it doesn't
matter who it is they don't want to go
there period because of the general
topic of what we're talking about and so
no there were there tended to be a a
pretty hard I wouldn't I wouldn't even
necessarily say it was just kind of like
an apathy in my experience as much as an
active I don't want to go there
I've been told that's off limits that's
out of bounds that guy's angry he's mad
I will say really quick I have a a
rather funny story
um this gentleman's actually an SDA
Pastor now down in Florida
um he was a theology major when I was
um a student and he was good friends
with one of my roommates and they didn't
know that um at the time I was attending
a non-denominational church
um I was not an Adventist while going
there but my my four roommates were very
staunch or three roommates I should say
I was the fourth were very staunch sdas
and I was actually
um I was in the living room one Saturday
and I was actually working on homework
they were doing the typical Sabbath
thing you know you go to church and then
you go to someone's house to eat and
then you go on a walk but only for about
an hour anything over an hour and it's
probably going to be work so
um they they all came back and I was
actually listening to a talk from Dale
laugh
and this gentleman came in and they were
talking about one of their friends who
they'd found out was going to in in in
his words one of those apostate churches
and they were they were that Sabbath out
walking with him trying to coach him
along
um why that was an issue Etc that's what
they came back discussing and I'm
sitting in the living room listening to
a Dale ratzlife talk on not through
headphones I mean through the speakers
or whatever
and this gentleman asked me he said hey
who are you who are you listening to
after saying that I said oh this is Dale
Ratz laugh
and the there was a tension that Rose in
the room he's a theology major so he
knows that name
um there's a tension that rises in the
room you can feel it and oh yeah I
didn't really feel it but I mean I guess
I I did I was I didn't feel out of place
I was just kind of way like are you
gonna you know I'm gonna I paused you
know I'm gonna get back to listening you
know and his response was
oh
that guy you're one of them
that's where it ended so it was those
sorts of things
um we don't want to go there or I've
been told about that person
so I'm not gonna go to the actual source
and actually see for myself I've already
been told by an authority Source that's
told me
don't listen to him
yep yep
so um since I had all these old books on
my bookshelf and I had spent
considerable time looking into the
subject with curiosity
I thought I would begin to document my
thoughts and the research of others
I decided my motto would be to test the
profit it would be a reminder to myself
to test her claims in order to make a
more informed consent
because the big question is was Ellen
who she claimed to be
and it hit me for the first time when I
began this endeavor
that as an Adventist I never really
asked myself that question before
it was just assumed given the fact that
myself and those in the community
believe the same as Ellen did and thus
how could she be a false prophet
so I began studying Ellen's claims and
writing notes on my observations which
are very slowly being turned into videos
I enjoy the research process much more
than putting it together for YouTube so
I'm quite behind
another thought I considered when I
began to ask questions is that in the
American legal system
one is innocent until proven guilty
and naturally we were raised in
adventism with the same understanding
toward Ellen White
we are born underneath her with the
presupposition that she was who she
claimed to be that she is innocent
but what if we had a different approach
what if we started with no
presupposition that Ellen was a true
prophet and then brought in evidence
that seems to support her claims while
also looking at those issues that seem
to point the other direction
to me it makes more sense to do it this
way because then you are really focusing
on what was allegedly amazing about her
and not ignoring the issues either
you know what is it that makes us say
yeah she was special
she definitely had Supernatural insight
and that is why looking at evidence
against her in my opinion is so
important
in contrast as we grew up in adventism
we only hear one side of that courtroom
we typically only hear the evidence that
supports her rather than the other side
or the cross-examination
and if we know that false prophets are
going to arise and appear to be sheep
but are truly inwardly wolves as Jesus
said
and man I want to inspect that sheep as
much as I can for any wolf
characteristics
false prophets are not always going to
be overt they will look and act like the
real thing that is why they will look
like sheep they will point to the Bible
they will incorporate scripture in their
books and write about Christ
so I decided I didn't want to Simply run
my fingers through the wall and say wow
this is really nice Ellen white sheep I
should follow her
instead I want to open up the mouth and
peer behind every tooth to see if
there's a Fang
I want to look under the wool of the
feet and see if there are claws
I want to take my flashlight and pry
open the eyelid of that animal and see
if there's something in the blackness
to just prove her wrong because I am
some monster
but to put her claims to the test
was she who she said she was
but what I realized was that a close
investigation hunting for Wolf
characteristics is largely is largely
discouraged
in my personal experience in adventism
objections made are not taken seriously
by most of those who believe her
they just spelled that Ellen predicted
people would fall away from her fling
their arms in the air yelling at the
shaking or warn you to be careful
this is because they start with the
premise that she is a true prophet and
cannot accept any evidence that calls
that belief into question
their presupposition is fixed and they
understand the grandiose claims she made
and that the question Ellen is in a
sense to question God reality or sanity
the obvious thought that arises to them
is there is no way I have been following
a false prophet
what I found interesting during my
studies
was that I also asked several fellow
Adventists to provide me with some
undeniable evidence that Ellen was a
true prophet
strong predictions Etc
tell me something that shows God's
handprint so I can consider that
evidence and make an informed decision
anyone who's listening to this right now
feel free to show in the comments after
this video is over what is your
undeniable proof that she was who she
claimed to be
make your best case
because what I found was that the old
and common arguments do not seem to work
after review of The Evidence
for example
if we remove her prolific writings made
possible by God as something remarkable
now that we know she had an extensive
library of 1500 books that she utilized
to write her books
well then we can't use that argument
anymore
if we say it was her physical
manifestations during her visions
I've come to another wall as I have
found every single physical
manifestation she was known for produced
in other young women during her time and
I have the evidence
so then we are left with a common
arguments of how she wrote beautiful
things on the Life of Christ
which begs the question
what has she done that another author
writing about Christ could not have done
in the 19th century or even today
I have their books and they were gifted
in writing especially viewed through a
21st century lens
moreover she was utilizing their
beautiful writings
so to argues she is a valid messenger
messenger of God because she wrote
beautiful things about Christ while at
the same time arguing she can take
whatever she wants
only reinforces the issue on the source
of her ideas
do we believe in Ellen's gift because
she used the words I saw or I was shown
I've demonstrated in my series that she
still used other I she still used others
ideas to construct these very moments of
alleged Supernatural revelation
that she couched with the words I saw or
I was shown
so again where's the proof
SDS tell me her health writings are true
backed by science and thus that is
certainly evidence that she was divinely
inspired
to that I found there's nothing special
about her health writings when you
compare them to books by the health
reformers of the 19th century that
predated her health message
further I found that young women in the
19th century who claimed Supernatural
Insight visions and even Communications
with the dead also promoted similar diet
reform principles such as vegetarianism
did they receive the health message too
and which supernatural guide gave them
those instructions
how about the claim that she only took
the true aspects of the health message
from others and left the false ideas to
the health reformers
here I find their conceptualization of
her health message incomplete
for example they're unaware that she
believed that eating meat or drinking
tea may cause one to engage in sexual
acts and these sexual acts would cause
one to to deplete their life battery and
die sooner
which is ridiculous and unproven
but this pseudoscience is what some of
the health reformers taught
and when Ellen absorbed these ideas
Adventists believed they were divinely
transmitted to the remnant to prepare
them to receive glorified bodies
so once again
I ask what is the proof that roughly 2
000 years after Christ
that I am now to follow the authority of
a young girl from the Northeastern
United States
at a time when having visions was
commonplace
what is the undeniable evidence that she
was the conduit
of the remnant Church John wrote about
in Revelation
so now with all that said
I thought in light of the debate over
the source of her material
we could begin tonight by revisiting the
foundation of Ellen's story
her story separated her from a mere
mortal writing a fictional story
poet attempting to come up with new Pros
her story is why individuals in the 19th
century and even today hand over their
cash to receive her information
as I explained earlier her story was one
of the great proofs of her credibility
when taught to us as children
so I knew this would be a great subject
to review
although only in brief tonight
miles what is usually the foundational
story that is told by members or pastors
when that you treat when they introduce
her gift
uh well in my experience and it's funny
uh that I'm going to mention this
because I was actually just uh
reminiscing over this earlier today in
the article I shared it folks in the
chat for those that are curious Ellen
White's big Bible
yeah
oh go ahead
no go ahead
um
I was going to say that
um the foundational story is her
Misfortune her injury as a kid oh oh oh
sorry I misunderstood what you were
saying um yeah but yeah the fact that
she was the fact that she was preserved
and she wasn't supposed to live and the
fact that God preserved her life
evidences the fact that she had this
calling she had this gifting and how
could a girl who only had a third grade
education be able to write all that
material and there's no way she could
have done that and how could this little
Fable girl held out this 18 pound Bible
for 30 minutes without breathing and
just yeah all that so interesting side
note uh since you brought up the the big
Bible
um so I've done a lot of research on the
physical manifestations of these young
women in the mid 19th century and I
found a book that mentioned that one of
the one of the proofs so to speak that
they had uh spiritual gifts
was that they would hold a heavy object
out at arm's length yeah Jim overhead
she's really fascinating it has a has a
video on that where he goes over a
number of individuals
um from that time period that all have
seemingly similar stories
now the sdas though will I've heard them
like Merlin Burt the current director of
the white estate I've heard him respond
to claims like that as right but they
weren't holding out the Bible which God
did that and I just saw this clip again
today from their documentary the white
Estates documentary that uh the fact
that she did that with the Bible it was
God using her to point us back to the
Bible so that's how we know it was a
legitimate event because unlike these
other ones they were pointing to
something else like this heavy object
they were lifting out she was holding
out the Bible and so it was it was
legitimate because clearly that means
that God was trying to use her to point
us back to the Bible
yeah
yeah right
it's The Hidden book yeah
um so
the story of her Misfortune how she was
tragically injured as a kid after being
hit with a rock in the face
is the foundational story of Ellen White
in fact she opens up her autobiography
life sketches as well as her first
testimony for the church by informing
them how sick and feeble she was after
this incident
and that she had to drop out of school
at the age of nine
the focus on her me this focus on her
meager education similar to other female
Visionaries of her day provided evidence
that her literary output should be
believed to have come from the
supernatural
she wrote in testimonies for the church
volume one
while I was but a child my parents
removed from Gorman Gorham to Portland
Maine
here at the age of nine years an
accident happened to me which was to
affect my whole life
in company with my twin sister in one of
our schoolmates I was crossing a common
in the city of Portland
when a girl about 13 years of age became
angry at some trifle followed us
threatening to strike us
our parents had taught us never to
contend with anyone
but if we were in danger of being abused
or injured to hasten home at once
we were doing this with all speed but
the girl followed us as rapidly with a
stone in her hand
I turned my head to see how far she was
behind me and as I did she threw the
stone and it hit me on the nose
I was stunned by the by the blow and
fell senseless to the ground
later in the chapter she wrote my health
seemed to be hopelessly impaired for two
years I could not breathe through my
nose and was able to attend school but
little
it seemed impossible for me to study and
to retain what I learned
the same girl who was the cause of my
Misfortune was appointed monitor by our
teacher
and it was among her duties to assist me
in my writing and other lessons
she always seemed sincerely sorry for
the great injury she had done me
although I was careful not to remind her
of it
she was tender and patient with me and
seemed sad and thoughtful
as she saw me laboring under serious
disadvantages to get an education
my nervous system was prostrated and my
hand trembled as so much as I made but
little progress in writing
and could get no further than the simple
copies in coarse hand
as I Endeavor to bend my mind to my
studies the letters on the page would
run together great drops of perspiration
perspiration would stand upon my brow in
a faintness and dizziness would seize me
I had a bad cough and my whole system
seemed debilitated
my teachers advised me to leave school
and not pursue my studies further till
my health should improve
it was the hardest struggle of my young
life to yield to my feebleness and
decide that I must leave my studies and
give up the hope of gaining an education
three years later I made another trial
to obtain an education but when I
attempted to resume my studies my health
rapidly failed and it became apparent
that if I remained in school
it would be at the expense of my life
I did not attend school after I was 12
years old
my ambition to become a scholar had been
very great and when I pondered over my
disappointed hopes and the thought that
I was to be an invalid for life
I was unreconciled to my lot and at
times murmured against the Providence of
God and thus afflicting me
this is what she wrote as the preface to
her launching into her alleged inspired
testimony to the church
to show how remarkable her story was and
that the Providence of God was
afflicting her now
so that her output later could show
God's glory
in order to accomplish this Ellen
emphasized her injury and sickness
and there's actually much more to this
Victorian concept of sickness which I
will discuss a little later tonight and
in a future video
but this story she told of her injury
was that while she had to drop out of
school and was too feeble to write
God eventually steadied her hand and
soon she was able to write page after
page with ease
she wrote later in the same testimony
volume in regards to the year after the
great disappointment
up to this time I could not write
my trembling hand was unable to hold a
pen steadily
while in while Envision I was commanded
by an Angel to write the vision
I obeyed and wrote steadily
my nerves were strengthened and from
that day to this my hand has been steady
until Ellen was chosen by God to receive
Visions she could not write
in time she would become a prolific
author writing on nearly every subject
one could imagine
however the more you think about it the
more questions arise over the
implications of this origin story
and if we're honest with ourselves the
account of Ellen's Misfortune is not a
peripheral Side Story either
rather it seems to be the foundation to
the believability of her gift and the
opening scene of every biography written
after
this tragedy of hers invoke curiosity
amazement and provided a foundation for
her extraordinary claims to the early
Adventist membership and even to them
today
without it people would attribute her
literary work as commonplace
however by reinforcing this trauma she
had grounds to be taken seriously and
was transformed into more than any other
author of her day and one with more than
ordinary knowledge
but her health didn't return to normal
after her hand was steadied
instead she routinely reminded
or mentioned her poor health and it
developed into a character of its own
for example in the 1849 broadside to
those who are receiving the Seal of the
Living God she wrote
I saw the state of some who stood on
present truth but disregarded the
Visions the way God had chosen to teach
in some cases Those Who aired from Bible
truth
I saw that in Striking against the
Visions they did not strike against the
worm the feeble instrument
Ellen that God spake through but against
the Holy Ghost I saw it was a small
thing to speak against the instrument
but it was dangerous to slight the words
of God
here she is equating her messages as the
words of God through her the feeble husk
she continued
I saw if there were an error and God
chose to show them their heirs their
visions
and they disregarded the teachings of
God through visions
they would be left to take their own way
and run in the way of error
and think that they were right until
they would find it out too late
then in the time of trouble I heard them
cry to God in agony
why bits thou not show us our wrong that
we might have got right and been ready
for this time
apparently the sdas who disregarded her
vision speaking King James English in
the future
then an angel pointed to me and said
my father taught but you would not be
taught he spoke through Visions but you
disregarded his vision through Ellen
and he gave you up to your own ways to
be filled with your own doings
what is notable about this early quote
is that Ellen highlighted that she was
the feeble instrument the husk in which
God spoke through
and to those who disregarded her vision
she gave them a preview by quoting their
words from the future well they cried
out in agony
we can see she was not your ordinary
soon-to-be author
she was a conduit of Heaven
while an early mention we find this
theme of her being a feeble instrument
recur throughout her lifetime
and also the implications of ignoring
Ellen's messages
for example you would be sliding God
himself
and by the way if you would like to see
how Ellen uses other authors to respond
to those who did slide her messages
who did slight her messages
my fifth video shows a lengthy example
of this
however before we leave this example as
a side note this is also the same
publication where you can find Ellen's
description of angels going in and out
of heaven with a golden card
and that the Seal of God is the Sabbath
there are many more examples I could
show tonight regarding her feebleness
but in in the interest of time we will
only look at a few more
so a few years later in 1860 Ellen
published her book spiritual gifts
volume 2.
in this volume she wrote about the time
in 1858 where she attended a funeral at
Lovett's Grove in Ohio
at this time she interrupted a funeral
service by having another alleged vision
and a grander vision this time of the
war between Christ his angels and Satan
and his angels She Wrote
in this Vision at Lovett's Grove most of
the matter of the great controversy
which I had seen 10 years before was
repeated and I was shown that I must
write it out
that I should have to contend with the
powers of Darkness for Satan would make
strong efforts to hinder me
but angels of God would not leave me in
the conflict that in God must I put my
trust
remember this theme of Satan making
strong efforts to hinder her we will
revisit this again in a few minutes
she continued
after I came out of vision remember she
interrupted a funeral
The Afflicted friends and a portion of
the congregation bore the body to its
resting place
great solemnity rested upon those who
remained
Monday we commenced our journey Homeward
with brother and sister Tillotson
the next day we took the cars at Fremont
for Jackson Michigan
while riding in the cars we arranged our
plans for writing and Publishing the
book called The Great controversy
immediately on our return home
I was then as well as usual
on the arrival of the train at Jackson
we went to Brother Palmers
we had been in the house but a short
time when I was conversing with
sister Palmer
my tongue refused to utter what I wish
to say and seem large and numb
a strange cold sensation struck my heart
passed over my head and down my right
side
for a while I was insensible but was
aroused by the voice of Ernest prayer
I tried to use my left arm and limb but
they were perfectly useless
for a short time I did not expect to
live
so here we find she's having weakness on
one side and the inability to talk
in any other situation these symptoms
may be consistent with a neurological
disorder such as a stroke
notice also that she was aroused by
people praying for her this is important
to remember
we will see later how others prayers
would resurrect so to speak Ellen from
our sickly episodes
let's continue on
it was the third shock I had received a
paralysis and although within 50 miles
of home I did not expect to see my
children again
I called to mine
the triumphant season I had enjoyed at
Lovett's Grove and thought it was my
last testimony and felt reconciled to
die
still the earnest prayers of my friends
were ascending to heaven for me and soon
a prickling sensation was felt in my arm
and limb and I praise the Lord that I
could use them a little
notice that once those around her began
to seek for God's glory to be manifested
she would recover from an illness she
claimed at the time
I noticed this pattern would happen over
and over again
she continued
the Lord heard and answered the faithful
prayers of his children and the power of
Satan was broken
that night I suffered much yet the next
day was strengthened to return home
for several weeks I could not feel the
pressure of the hand or the coldest
water poured upon my head
in Rising to walk I often staggered and
sometimes fell to the floor
now she claims in this condition I
commenced to write the great controversy
I could write it first but one page a
day then rest three
but as I progressed my strength
increased the numbness in my hand did
not seem to be cloud my mind and before
I closed the work
the the effect of the shock had entirely
left me
at the time of the conference at Battle
Creek June 1858 sister Hutchins who now
sleeps in Jesus was greatly Afflicted
with sickness
and we all felt that she would then go
down into the grave unless the Lord
raised her up
while praying for her the power of God
rested upon us
and as It Came Upon me I was taken off
in vision
in that Vision I was shown that in the
sudden attack at Jackson
Satan designed to take my life to hinder
the work I was about to write
but angels of God were sent to my rescue
to raise me above the effects of Satan's
attack attacks
so there is this recurring theme
of overcoming sickness in order to write
her books and that Satan was attempting
to stop her from sharing the light from
heaven
she didn't have to mention she was sick
but continually chose to remind the
early Adventists about her feeble state
she said in this condition I commenced
to write the great controversy
what's interesting is that the
victorians believed that the more feeble
and sickly a young woman was the more in
touch with the supernatural they were
which is such a fascinating topic I'm
looking forward to share more about in
the future
so in that setting by Ellen reinforcing
her injured State she is appealing to
this notion of Supernatural connection
and placing herself right in the middle
of the great controversy conflict
between Christ and Satan as being the
medium that information would flow to
the remnant Church
former associate Secretary of the white
estate Roger remarked in his book
The Great visions of Ellen G white
this book The Great controversy very
nearly cost her her life literally
the story of the background circum
circumstances of this vision is almost
as exciting as the far-reaching content
of the vision itself
her health and her stories very closely
woven in adventism
moving forward in 1871
her husband James wrote in the review
and Herald
and Mrs White also is sharing very
largely the divine blessing
for two years past she has most of the
time suffered from painful and
discouraging evidence of a growing
cancer in her breast
about the time we decided to
about the time we decided to never leave
the work at Battle Creek until the Lord
and his people gave us unmistakable
evidence
that we were released
Mrs White gave herself to the Lord Anew
in a covenant to trust in his power
fully
we bowed before God together in a solemn
a solemn Covenant to be holy his
and to labor on
trusting his providential hand to uphold
to direct and to save
and the Lord has been very gracious to
us Mrs White is free and happy and has
the best of evidence that the growing
cancer is swelling which has become
large and was very painful is entirely
removed
as we pen these lines she is by our side
earnestly preparing her second volume of
the spirit of Prophecy for the Press
while not related to her Misfortune as a
child
this pattern continues of sickness and
then Supernatural healing
here we see Ellen had a cancerous growth
in her breast then Ellen and James
claimed they prayed to the Lord then
miraculously the cancer was removed
then the public was reminded she is
preparing her next book release
how could anyone doubt the origin of her
written insights when she can pray and
have a cancerous mass removed
so you can see how her health played a
large role in her believability
the glory of the Lord was once again
manifested through the feeble instrument
plus this is such a great manifestation
no one can prove Ellen didn't have a
cancerous lump in her breast only Ellen
and James would know this
you know I'm sure Ellen wasn't walking
around saying hey Uriah come feel this
lump in my breast
well unless they were by chance at an
Israel Daemon party then who knows
so the only two who could prove this was
James and Ellen
further the next year she wrote to her
brother ball and lamented about this
suspected breast cancer and going
through menopause
most of my time I have been utterly
unable to write a simple letter it is
the change of life within me and for
three weeks at a time I am frequently
unable to tax the brain
this was my condition when I received
your letter and before I had recovered I
was afflicted with my cancer making it
impossible to write at all
again observe how she paints herself
being placed in a poor health situation
where she cannot write books unless God
fixes her
my husband and myself then United our
prayers for four days for help from God
our prayers were answered I awoke one
morning free from pain in my cancer
Bunch all gone
I felt grateful to God for his token of
his mercy and tender love
now I have to say miles
if we come to the conclusion that Ellen
White was a false prophet
and I believe the evidence points
strongly to that conclusion when taken
in its entirety
then the way the whites use cancer to
promote selling more books is deplorable
it is an insult to anyone who has gone
through the mental and physical anguish
of cancer
furthermore it also proves that the
health message does not prevent one from
developing cancer
unless we also assume Ellen was not
practicing what what she preached
and if she wasn't following her health
message that means she ran the risk of
feebling her intellect by her own health
message standards and thus would be an
even poorer candidate for transmitting
light from heaven
but before we move on
let's visit that new book The Spirit of
Prophecy volume 2.
that James advertised that she was now
able to finish
now that God removed her cancer
let's read what the preface says
the author Ellen White
as a religious writer and speaker has
labored for the public during more than
20 years
being aided in the study of the
scriptures and in her work as a
religious teacher
by the special Enlightenment of the
spirit of God she is peculiarly
qualified
to present the facts of the life and
Ministry of Christ
in connection with the divine plan of
human Redemption
and to practically apply the lessons of
Jesus to the simple duties of life
notice how it is stated that she was
aided in the study of the scriptures not
other authors
I think this is a fundamental point
some Ellen enthusiasts claim she used
other books as a storyline guide to
write her biblical narratives
even though she did not publicly
announce that I am aware that she was
working in that manner
but why on Earth would she need another
author's book when she had the
scriptures to serve as her storyline
guide
what source could be better than the
scriptures
it's also written here that she was
enlightened by the spirit of God and
that is why she is qualified to present
the facts of the life and Ministry of
Christ
she had seen visions and spoken with God
so if she is qualified then she should
be able to write without being dependent
on other authors who did not claim
special qualifications
just think about it why else would sdas
care with some uneducated Victorian
woman had to say on biblical matters
when there were numerous books by
educated theologians at the local
bookstore
does the preface say she was uniquely
qualified to search other books to find
content to that to add to the biblical
narrative no and this occurred at a time
when special Enlightenment was given to
countless young women who claim that
their new knowledge came from the
supernatural
any thoughts miles
nope keep going brother
but now moving back to our health
let me illustrate in the interest of
time two more examples
in 1906 in writing about her camp
meeting experience in Helzberg
California
Ellen lamented on how the death of her
husband the year before in 1881 almost
commenced her own death
the year that followed my husband's
death was filled with suffering for me
I did not think I could live I became so
weak
the idea came to members of my family
that there would be a spark of hope for
me if I could be induced to attend this
sorry if I could be induced to attend
the camp meeting in Helzberg
this meeting was to be held in a Grove
about half a mile from my home in
Helzberg
they hoped that on the campground
God would reveal to me distinctly that I
was to live
there was at the time no color in my
face but a deadly paleness
they took me to the campground one
Sunday in an easy carriage
that day the large tent was full it
seemed as if nearly all Helzberg was
present
notice the setup for the glory of God to
be manifested in the feeble instrument
she was once again ill
and the large tent was full to see the
prophet speak and she wrote that they
hoped they would see a sign a physical
manifestation that she was to live
a perfect moment for another
demonstration of God's glory and
confirmation of her position
she continues
a lounge was placed on the broad
platform that served as a Pulpit and on
it I was made as comfortable as possible
during the meeting I said to my son
Willie White
will you help me up and assist me to
stand on my feet while I say a few words
he said that he would and I got up
for five minutes I stood there trying to
speak and thinking that it was the last
speech I should ever make my farewell
message
all at once I felt a power come upon me
like a shock of electricity
it passed through my body and up to my
head
the people said that they plainly saw
the blood mounting to my lips my ears my
cheeks my forehead
before that large number of people I was
healed
and the praise of God was in my heart
and came from my lips in clear tones
a miracle was wrought before that large
congregation
I then took my place among the speakers
and before the congregation bore
testimony such as they had never before
heard
it was as if one had been raised from
the dead
that whole year had been one of
preparation for this change
and this sign the people in Helzberg
were to have as a witness for the truth
this healing of the feeble woman
reinforced to those in the crowd that
the Lord was up upholding her and
speaking through her to the early band
of avenus
now if you're wondering if this was if
you're wondering if this was a single
episode it was not I found she did this
repeatedly
this pattern persisted in many of her
camp meetings for example She Wrote
attended camp meeting in New York in New
York and labored as God gave me strength
returned worn and exhausted to Battle
Creek and was obliged to refrain from
speaking for a Time
attended camp meeting at Wexford
Michigan and the Lord strengthened me to
speak to the people
after the after the meeting I was again
prostrated through over labor
attended the camp meeting in Kalamazoo
and the Lord strengthened me to speak in
labor for the people
returning home to Battle Creek I was
again prostrated but the Lord help me
I attended the meeting in Saginaw and to
the praise of God he raised me above my
feebleness and I was made strong when
before the people
after the meeting I was again greatly
prostrated but started on my journey to
attend camp meeting in Colorado
the Lord greatly blessed me in these
meetings as I bore my testimony
I then continued my journey to
California
I spoke twice to the people in Helzberg
attended Oakland meeting and was very
sick
but the Lord Raised Me Up and
strengthened me with his spirit and
power and I spoke to the people eight
times and several times before
committees and ministers and in morning
meetings
it's as if when she was invited to a
camp meeting to speak she would preface
those that invited her with I am feeble
I do not have the strength to speak
however after they would pray for her
pray for her
she would arrive stand up and then
suddenly be endowed with strength and
vigor to show how how God's glory was
manifested
this is one of the observations I made
when I began to wonder if Ellen was
truly this sick person that God was
healing over and over
remember Ellen prefaced her work in life
with her childhood injury
the setting
a per chronic feebleness
and it was interesting to me when I
surveyed the literature
that Victorian women use sickness as a
spiritual gifts right of passage
for example
Alex Owen a professor of history at
Northwestern University wrote women
mediums and laying stress on the role of
sickness in their early lives at once
appealed to the to the definition of
woman as invalid and laid the groundwork
for a strong spiritual pedigree
the motif of youthful illness was woven
into a scenario of lonely unhappy or
difficult childhoods
a not uncommon theme in Victorian
autobah autobiography writing
a sense of early deprivation was
accompanied by an ethos
of morbid sensibility and intimations or
indications of a spiritual calling
so victorians believe that an early
illness or difficult childhood
would or could indicate a spiritual
calling
miles I've perused a number of books by
Victorian young women over the past year
claim Supernatural gifts to see if
Ellen's story was as unique as it was
claimed in Sabbath School
well to my surprise it was not
many of these young girls claim some
illness or injury in their childhood and
then subsequent spiritual gifts Visions
abilities but most of all knowledge from
the supernatural Realm
this knowledge was touted as remarkable
because they usually lacked in education
and that lack of because became one of
their Chief claims of their legitimacy
they would say that they have read
nothing on the subject they were
presenting and then they would give a
speech or write a book
the sickness connected them in the eyes
of the victorians as being primed for
the spiritual Realm
so in a way it was advantageous for them
to be sick
to be feeble
James and Allen wrote a defense to those
who did not believe in Ellen's gift in
their 1880 autobiography life sketches
and it really ties all this together
they wrote
peculiar experience and extensive labors
of Mrs White have called out expressions
from the pious from the curious
and from those who have cherished a
spirit toward her and her work as bitter
as Gaul
and the Very nature of the case seems to
demand that we should make the following
points
now if there was ever a defense to those
who did not believe in her gifts here is
what the whites claim as their evidence
um had Mrs White been spared the blow
which made her an invalid in her
childhood
had she grown to Womanhood with health
and strength to obtain a finished
education
and had she come before the people under
these favorable circumstances as a
speaker and writer
the unbelief of our time so ready to
seize upon objections would have given
the credit of her work to the woman and
not to the Lord
for the special work connected with the
last message at this time of
unparalleled skepticism God chose a
feeble means that his power might be
clearly manifested and that the glory of
his work might be given to the
instrument
pay attention because this is very
important
here James is presenting Ellen as a
sickly Victorian woman with amazing
abilities
the ability to speak in front of a crowd
as a woman caused amazement to Victorian
men
I've read where people would literally
line up and pay money to watch a woman
speak in front of a crowd
cause Jaws to drop
that is how novel that site was
so observe how James and Ellen's
argument argument is that in order for
God's power to be clearly manifested
she needed to be feeble so they could
credit her work as a speaker and writer
to the Lord
she must be sickly for her story and
output to be believable as a sign of
God's glory
this is why her misfortunate injury with
a rock to the face as young girl and her
ongoing sickly State thereafter was
important
this is why before she walked on stage
to give a speech she was weak and then
after prayer she would be able to speak
if she had not been feeble and was able
to obtain a finished education she would
be like any other author writing books
remember that she was not even able to
write it all until she claimed the Lord
calmed the Tremors and then spoke what
he wanted her to write
thus to me it would be it would make
perfect sense that you would avoid
mentioning your indebtedness to other
authors
outside of her book on world history
as that would affect the clear
manifestation of God's glory in a feeble
instrument writing the light from heaven
as we have seen so far with her a great
controversy vision
Ellen would not miss a chance to inform
others at the battle that enraged
between God and Satan over her health
and in the example to follow I can see
why one would argue that she was using
her feebleness as a story element
because in 1890 Ellen wrote a response
to Matthew Larson
an Adventist Pastor from Iowa who openly
rebuked her in a meeting held in Battle
Creek the same year
in this letter she felt the need to
remind him of her sickly State and her
connection with the supernatural
a colleague pointed out to me that in
this letter her personal feelings and
acknowledgment of Supernatural strength
and barriers of Satan generated from
krumacher's 1828 book Elijah the Tish
fight
She Wrote
if God strengthens me as he did on the
last Sabbath and every day since I shall
feel myself strengthened with a
courageous and joyful spirit
for I experience within me a divine
power by which and through which I can
accomplish the work he has given me to
do
Satan's work has been to erect barriers
against me and my work that would keep
my message from coming to the people he
would Rejoice to have me in weakness and
to see me trembling at the sight of
dangers which surround me in mountains
of difficulties which rise before me
so while the great controversy started
in heaven it appears to be closing with
God and Satan battling over Ellen's
Health work and the continued mountains
of difficulty which rise before her
I find it interesting that she says
Satan rejoices when she was weak because
not only was the Victorian expectation
that a great medium would be sickly
but it was when she was weak that she
claimed God's glory was manifested by
pulling her out of that state
without her weakness she was nothing
she continued
my nature shrinks but notwithstanding I
Advance with holy boldness to meet one
difficulty after another
which arises to obstruct my way and yet
I move forward in the name of the Lord
in simple Faith to meet them relying
upon him who was eternally near and who
will go with me and who will when it is
for his name's Glory
rebuke with a word the ocean's wave
and thrash the mountains that they shall
become a plane
isn't it fascinating how Ellen needed
another author to describe how God
strengthened her to describe how Satan
was erecting barriers against her and
that Satan was enjoying her weakened
state
was she not able to write what she knew
about the war around her herself
and when we read sections in her books
of on how Satan is attacking her or
about her health
we must ask was what she wrote genuine
or was this all a ploy to demonstrate
God working through her
or to appeal to the Victorian ideal of
spiritual gifts
what was most interesting in my research
is that historians have noted that 19th
century female Visionaries would at
times exaggerate or even fabricate their
childhood sicknesses in order to appear
closer to the supernatural
and a better candidate as a medium
and one must Ponder if Ellen did the
same
if you recall it wasn't only her
speaking Endeavors that was made
possible by God but also her writings
in fact Arthur white grandson of Ellen
White and previous director of the white
estate included in his biography of her
toward the end of
the first paragraph here
that the real issue was the reliability
of the testimonies and the basis of her
writings
on Monday March 10 she Ellen had
responded to a letter of inquiry from
Elder Colcord in which she made a sole
revealing statement about her call and
work
Ellen wrote
your question I will answer as best I
can
I take no credit of ability in myself to
write the articles in the paper or to
write the books which I publish
certainly I could not originate them
I have been receiving light for the last
45 years and I've commun I have been
communicating to light given me of
Heaven to our people as well as to all
whom I could reach
I am seeking to do the will of my
heavenly father
would any other Victorian author write
something like this besides are there
prophets or mediums of her day
this is why the SDA apologists arguments
were flawed in my opinion as they hunt
for quotes from novelists who are fed up
with plagiarism accusations in the
Victorian era and wrote out against it
in an attempt to explain her habits
she's so far removed from a novelist
attempting to reinvent a mystery plot
and being frustrated with diminishing
plot lines and subsequent accusations of
plagiarism
in contrast Alan claimed she did not
have the ability to write the book she
published that they contained the light
given to her from heaven and that she
was doing the will of her Heavenly
Father
furthermore she takes no credit of
ability in herself to write the book she
published
so if she is a borrowing or adapting
gems from other authors that would mean
she would have the ability to write and
could claim credit for what she wrote
as you can see the SD arguments fall
short in many areas
since I have shown two examples from
1890 where she discussed her weakness
and how her writings came about
and in light of the debate over the real
source of her information
let's take a look at a famous example
from the same year of where she claimed
she was doing the will of her Heavenly
Father by speaking the words given to
her from God through a Heavenly God
to those unaware Ellen would sometimes
use Diaries that's as scratch pads for
later published material
a perfect way to generate new insights
from Heaven by writing down excerpts
from books in our library
she began her November 21 1890 diary on
the right this way
during the ninth season which means
nighttime
I was specially moved upon by the spirit
of God
my soul had been drawn out in Earnest
supplication to God
I was distressed on account of the
backsliding of his people
while lying in bed unable to sleep
because of the burden resting upon me I
was pleading with the Lord
I fell asleep and in the ninth season I
was taught of God
my guide said I have a work for you to
do you must speak the words given you by
the Lord
after these words have been spoken your
duty here is done
you are not required to enter into
details before individuals whatever
excuse me whatever may be their position
or work if they do not recognize the
voice of God in the message he gives you
to bear in his name
all your efforts to remove their doubts
will be of no avail if they gather the
Clouds Of Darkness around their souls
if you enter into particulars you weaken
the message it is not you speaking but
the Lord speaking through you
those who want to know the will of God
who do not desire to follow their own
will and judgment will be easily
entreated
they will be ready to discern the right
way
you'll notice on the LNG white writings
website that that the next paragraph is
in quotation marks
evidently these are the exact words
given her by the Lord through this guide
that she must speak
the wise and wherefores are concealed
from you yet speak the words I give you
however painful it may be to you
the ways in which God leads his people
are generally mysterious you have asked
to know God's way
your supplication has been answered God
knows better than you
that God knows better than you do what
is good and essential for his children
he never leads them otherwise then they
would wish to be led if they were able
to see as clearly as he does
the people whom God is leading must
venture out upon his word
they must walk forward by faith
so she claims she was moved upon by the
spirit of God she then fell asleep and
was taught to speak the words given her
by the Lord using the Heavenly guide
she claims this heavenly guy told her
these things which are actually from a
German author that was translated to
English and was known to be in Ellen
White's collection
furthermore this was placed in quotation
marks
miles given
she used this book quite a bit to
generate material I'm having a hard time
coming to the conclusion she received
this information from a Heavenly God
how about you miles
do you think this is truly light from
heaven
well no
um and I would kind of thinking back on
something you were saying earlier about
if uh you're essentially to the effect
saying if she was gifted like this why
was she needing to borrow from other
writers I'm thinking the same thing
around
or you were saying if the Bible is far
superior to these other writers was
isn't the Bible enough and I'm thinking
to myself
um if you're getting direct Revelation
from God why are you needing to borrow
from other authors
you have the source of
all knowledge revealing something to you
which this kind of gets into the insight
about how
um the the nature of scripture and how
the Adventist Church has a very
um
they they don't understand that the
authority of scripture the level of
scripture this gets into Soul scriptura
Prima scriptura these sorts of things
that they claim to affirm yet they don't
really understand the the the meat
behind these statements because it's all
ultimately rooted in The Source by which
it's coming from that's why scripture is
ontologically different for example when
we discuss with our Roman Catholic
friends why scripture is ontologically
different than tradition because of the
source by which it's coming from is God
himself so you've kind of got the same
thing going on here that
um this is coming from God yet she's
doing uh literary borrowing we'll say
um and it's supposedly supposed to be uh
no different than scripture in terms of
um inspiration which again that gets
into their faulty understanding of what
that is but all of that to say uh no I'm
not buying it
right it's as if she had a vision and
then scratched her head and said man I
don't know how to write that out you
know either either she understood the
concepts and was able to write it out or
she went looking for stuff
yeah and this gets into their whole
thought inspiration and thought gems and
and all those sorts of things right
right
um I figured for those unaware I should
show a few more quotes where she
described her literary work and from the
last 15 years of her life
in 1900 she wrote my work has been in
the field since 1845.
ever since then I have labored with pen
and voice
increased light has come to me as I have
been part of the light given me
I have very much more light on the Old
and New Testament scriptures which I
shall present to our people
here Ellen claimed she was she has been
imparting the light given to her with
pen and voice
this is why avenus purchased her books
for that imparted light
who wouldn't want special insight into
the scriptures
who wouldn't want a modern day
connection with the divine
but here's where Ellen apologists get
excited inventive and attempt to create
literary or relativism
by stating much of what she took from
other authors was simply added details
to enhance the biblical story
but not actually part of the light from
heaven
Ellen however did not make a distinction
between what was light and what was
Superfluous details and further she
condemned those that tried to
differentiate what was inspired and what
was not
also she states that she has or that she
had very much more light on the Old and
New Testament scriptures
miles I thought she didn't add anything
to the Bible isn't isn't that what
evidence claim
that's what they like to tell us
um even though like you mentioned
earlier angels with golden cards and
Satan actually plucked the fruit and
placed it in Eve's hand and she wandered
away from Adam and she disobeyed a
warning from an angel who said don't do
that there's been this Fallen powerful
foe from Heaven that is going to come
along and will tempt you and
um but yeah I mean no she added nothing
to the Bible she only expounds upon
what's already there
right
three years later she wrote to her son
this is included in selected messages
I cannot at my own impulse take up a
work and launch out into it I have to be
impressed by the spirit of God I cannot
write unless the Holy Spirit helps me
sometimes I cannot write it all then
again I'm aroused at 11 12 and 1 o'clock
and I can write as fast as my hand can
move over the paper
so was she able to write without the
intervention of God
it doesn't look like it
by her admission she wasn't able to
write unless the Holy Spirit helped her
and yet we're told we shouldn't worry
about where she found the information to
write her books she's just mining for
gems
and lastly Ellen wrote late in her life
in 1907 in regards to her work to a uh
brother Wilcox
dear brother Wilcox I received and read
your recent letter regarding the sister
who thinks that she has been chosen to
fill the position that sister white has
occupied
I have this to say she may be honest
that she is certainly deceived
about a year after the death of my
husband I was very feeble and it was
feared that I might live but a short
time
at the heldsburg camp meeting I was
taken into the tent where there was a
large Gathering of our people
I asked to be raised up from the lounge
on which I was lying and assisted to the
speakers platform
that I might say a few words are
farewell to the people
as I tried to speak the power of God
Came Upon me and thrilled me through and
through
many in the congregation observe that I
was weak and that my face and hands
seemed bloodless
but as I began speaking they saw the
color coming into my lips and face and
knew that a miracle was being wrought in
my behalf
I stood before the people healed and
spoke with freedom
the Assurance was given me you are not
alone in the work of the Lord
has chosen you to do
you will be taught of God how to bring
the truth and its Simplicity before the
people
the god of truth will sustain you and
convincing proof will be given that he
is leading you
God will give you of His Holy Spirit and
his grace and wisdom and keeping power
will be with you
if you recall as we saw earlier this
demonstration at Helzberg of overcoming
feebleness was one of the proofs of
religion of her legitimacy
and she continues to use it to reinforce
her gifts to brother Wilcox
she continues
abundant light has been given to our
people in these last days whether or not
my life is spared my writings will will
constantly speak and their work will go
forward as long as time shall last
my writings are on file in the office
and even though I should not live these
words that have been given to me by the
Lord
it's kind of interesting there these
words that have been given to me by the
Lord
is that verbal inspiration uh we'll
still have life and we'll speak to the
people
I thank God for the Assurance of his
love and that I have daily his leading
and guidance
I am very busy with my writing early and
late I'm writing out the matters that
the Lord opens before me
the burden of my work is to prepare
people to stand in the day of the Lord
never have testimonies been more clearly
brought before the people than those
that have been recently traced by my pen
so one thing I want to mention here is
that in my study I found that men would
boast in the mid 19th century
that they were able to cause women to be
to to essentially become Prophets
these women would go would then go out
into the world and give their warnings
and reproofs
I'll cover this later on my channel
Ellen continued
God bids me urged upon the attention of
our people the importance of their study
let this work begin now then whether I
am permitted to labor or I am laid away
to rest until Jesus comes
these messages are immortalized
this story woven throughout her lifetime
was that she was special
she was the girl who dropped out of
school and was taught by heaven and she
shared her testimonies with the early
avenists to prepare them to stand in the
day of the Lord because they were not
ready
so let's look now at an example from one
of these testimonies
testimonies to the church volume 5.
I discussed this example in my fifth
video so this will be a highly truncated
version
I'm only revisiting this for those who
are not Adventists or who are unfamiliar
unfamiliar with these claims
so if you're curious the the fifth video
on my channel goes into this testimony
in much more depth
for those tuning in who are unfamiliar
with her testimonies these were a
collection of documents and books that
Ellen wrote to the church that were
allegedly from light God had given her
to give to the church to shape them up
for the second coming
however some doubt it or ignored what
she had to say to them and this chapter
was a response to those who were not
following her light
She Wrote
yet now when I send you a testimony of
warning and reproof many of you many of
you declare it to be merely the opinion
of sister White
you have thereby insulted the spirit of
God
you know how the Lord has manifested
himself through the spirit of Prophecy
which is Adventist lingo for Ellen White
past the present and future have passed
before me
I have been shown faces that I have
never seen and years afterward I knew
them when I saw them
I have been aroused from my sleep with a
vivid sense of subjects previously
presented to my mind and I have written
at midnight letters that have gone
across the continent and arriving at a
crisis have saved great disaster to the
cause of God
this has been my work for many years
a power has impelled me to reprove and
rebrook rebuke wrongs that I had not
thought of
is this work of the last 36 years from
above
from beneath
so again Grandy's grandiose claims here
she claimed to have seen the past what
was going on in the present had also
seen the future
further she reinforced a binary position
of her work
that her work was either from the
Heavenly Throne or it was of the devil
what we just read are the kind of
statements that keep Evan is fearful of
testing her validity
because no one wants to insult God
especially when they're on probation
I don't want to sound cynical but miles
isn't this the perfect setup
picturing having a doctrine that states
there's a record of Christians acts
words and even their most secret motives
that all have their weight in deciding
their Destiny for wheel or woe
these will later come up at an unknown
time to decide their Destiny and then
have someone in that movement stand up
and claim their warnings are not their
opinion but gods and that they should be
followed
and to add that doubting Ellen White is
an insult to God
I mean can you imagine the anxiety some
of these people had when Ellen wrote a
testimony
next we will turn to page 67 in this
same testimony
she wrote when I went to Colorado I was
so burdened for you the Battle Creek
Church
that in my weakness again notice
weakness I wrote many I wrote many pages
to be read at your camp meeting weak and
trembling I arose at three o'clock in
the morning to write to you
God was speaking through clay you might
say this communication was only a letter
yes it was a letter but prompted by the
spirit of God
remember that in 1901 as we saw earlier
she claimed that I cannot have my own
impulse take up a work and launch out
into it I have to be impressed by the
spirit of God
I cannot write unless the Holy Spirit
helps me
notice again the pattern
she is weak then she is prompted by God
and she is able to write out what she
was shown
and yet the Adventist Defenders want us
to believe that she was simply an expert
compiler now that we learned that she
was using others material
she continues
yes it was a letter but prompted by the
spirit of God to bring before your minds
things that have been shown me
in these letters which I write notice
the present tense
in the testimonies I bear such as this
testimony we are reading currently
I am presenting to you that which the
Lord has presented to me
I do not write one article in the paper
expressing merely my own ideas
there what God has opened before me and
vision the precious rays of light
shining from the throne
it's statements like these that
illustrate why we should care about her
about where her information comes from
if what is in her books is a result of
her browsing the local library for
material
then it brings her claims into question
they're not supposed to be her ideas she
is presenting that which the Lord
presented to her
however SDA apologists want to argue
that God initially presented the
material to her
but I guess it was too complicated for
her feeble mind or maybe too simple and
so she had to browse her library to then
write out what she heard from above
or something to that effect
evidently the voice of the library was
more clear than the voice from heaven
so now we will look at just a couple
examples from this same testimony that
she claimed were rays of light shining
from the throne
FW crewmacher's book Elijah the tishvite
was published in English in 1838 44
years before this testimony and
originally published in a different
country
this is the same book she lifted her
experience regarding the barrier Satan
had placed in front of her that we
looked at earlier and much more
on the right in red you will find her
description of things she had seen in
vision the rest of the colors are what
she has taken from krumacher to explain
her visions
She Wrote
I have been shown that unbelief in the
testimonies she is referring to her
writings to the church here
have been steadily increasing as the
people backslide from God
it is all through our ranks all over the
field
but few know what our churches are to
experience
I saw that at present we are under
Divine forbearance
but no one can say how long this will
continue
no one knows how great the mercy that
has been exercised toward us
but few are heartily devoted to God
there are only a few who like the stars
in a tempestuous night shine here and
there among the clouds
one warns those in the S teachers that
few know what the SDA churches are about
to experience
she's warning those who do not believe
in her inspired testimonies that she has
seen the future and that at the present
time there was divine forbearance or
restraint based on what she saw in
vision
and yet she was following along in
another book generating material for
this inspired testimony
I'm sure there were many early
Adventists who received her testimonies
and debated whether she was a true
prophet
even today many wonder if one salvation
depends on how we follow Ellen White's
guidelines because she wrote that
ignoring them would be an insult to God
it's such a gray area for many
Adventists
later on in this testimony She Wrote
may the Lord have mercy upon you those
in Battle Creek
for if you go on in this way nothing but
evil could be prophesied concerning you
the patience of God has an object but
you are defeating it
as you can see there's this premonition
of Destruction if they avoid the light
she has secretly passed on from other
authors
and it's exam and it's examples like
these that really highlight that she
didn't just sit on her front porch and
rocking her chair yelling to sdas
walking by to go read the Bible
instead she had a significant role as a
messenger that brought her from being a
Victorian woman with no platform
to one that placed her in a position
higher than the men in her day
that's just the facts whether her claims
are true or not
the Victorian era was very patriarchal
with the women
having very little place to speak or
instruct men
the only way women could get around this
restriction was to have visions and with
Ellen being convinced of millerism early
in her life
a plausible Theory I've come to is that
she was able to continue to propagate
her convictions on the soon apocalypse
by claiming to receive light from heaven
for at that point
men and others had to take her and her
ideas seriously
further she tied ignoring her light from
heaven and sliding the Creator
so she wasn't just pointing to the Bible
she was also pointing to the books she
copyrighted and had for sale
and with probation looming over
everyone's heads
who is going to bet who she wasn't who
she claimed to be
she wrote that her work was either from
above or from beneath
so the problem I have is when you find
Visions details and claimed experiences
in her writings that came from other
authors and even from other Visionaries
while claiming she cannot launch out
into her Works without the help of the
Holy Spirit
it causes one to pause and reflect on if
her claims were true
I feel that it's completely appropriate
to raise this question because you can
see an alternative way of how the holy
of how the whole story could have been
constructed
because no matter what argument is put
forth in her defense
it doesn't negate that a false prophet
could have done the same thing
that realization is what drives us to
test her claims from all angles
we know that Ellen claimed to have seen
the past present and future including
the end of the world right
so
so if she writes about the end of the
world and uses God's words in quotation
marks
what in evidence expect this to be
something she had seen or heard envision
I was talking to a former Adventist
Pastor one day and he shared with me
an example from Charles Beecher a
presbyterian minister in his book
Redeemer and redeemed from 1864.
he also shared the column without excuse
Ellen White published in the review and
Herald in 1901 36 37 years later
here on the right
she wrote there is no excuse for sin it
will be the final condemnation of
Lucifer and his angels that one God
shall ask why have you done this they
will be able to assign no reason
and when at the last great day Sinners
are confronted with their sins and are
asked why did you transgress every mouth
will be stopped
the sinful will stand speechless before
God
now Ellen was known in her community as
one who uh to have to see how
Ellen White was known in her community
as one to have seen how the end would
come
that is the presupposition that
Adventists hold when reading her books
the question becomes why would she need
to take a book off her bookshelf sit
down at a table with both with both
books side by side and purposely
generate what God would say to Satan and
all the hosts of rebellion
either she had seen this and was
qualified to write on the matter or she
should have been more forthright when
she read a great quote from another
author and decided to place the words of
God in quotation marks based on the
materials she read
if she really saw God saying this then
she would not need Beecher to bring this
out she could just write what she saw
and heard
but while this is a more direct use of
this selection from Beecher Ellen also
used this passage previously to form the
ending of her origin of evil chapter in
the 1884 great controversy although more
veiled this time
let's look at another example
on the left we have the book the great
teacher by John Harris a congregational
Minister from England
this Edition published in 1856
on the right we have an article entitled
God's care for his people by Ellen White
published in signs of the times in 1898
She Wrote
the Lord is in active communication with
every part of his vast dominions
he is Representatives
bending toward the earth and its
inhabitants
he is listening to every word that is
uttered he hears every groan he listens
to every prayer
he observes the movements of everyone he
approves or condemns every action
the hand of Christ draws aside the veil
which conceals from our eyes the glory
of Heaven
and we Behold Him in his high and holy
place
not in a state of silence and
indifference to his subjects in a fallen
world but surrounded by all the Heavenly
hosts
Ten Thousand Times Ten Thousand and
thousands of thousands all waiting to go
at his bidding on errands of mercy and
love
so if you're an Adventist reading this
column you would think that what Ellen
writes here is beautiful
as insights granted to her from her time
with the divine
and yet this is just another example of
how she utilized her extensive library
of over 1500 books
to generate more more material as the
spirit of Prophecy
now why would I say that
because I've seen where she will follow
along in a book giving insight into a
Biblical passage and then claim an
experience that is literally the next
sentence in the book she's taken from
I have seen where she denied reading
books on health before writing her books
out
but I have been able to track down some
of these rare books and have caught her
in a lie and when one finds that their
prophetess has lied about the source of
their information
why would any rational person not
question her gift
the whole story of her feebleness and
low education like many other young
women of her day was the storyline they
used to make their abilities of
providing information all the more
remarkable
again a lot to speak on that topic but
you'll have to wait for that
presentation
so I thought we could close with one
more example I stumbled across
when reading some of her earlier
material
this time we won't be looking at her
literary habits per se
but an example from her first book in
one of her earliest visions
now we know avenists are known for their
adherence to the Sabbath
but what is not as well known is that
Ellen White was not a Sabbath Keeper at
first
and that she changed her Visions based
on her new understanding of the Sabbath
let me show you
here is the January 24th 1846
publication of the day star a millerite
periodical
given the age of the publication the
quality of the scans are poor
unfortunately
according to the SDA encyclopedia e
Jacobs was the publisher and editor of
his periodical
and he would receive letters from
readers urging fellow Believers to
maintain their faith in an imminent
second Advent and not fall by the
wayside
so one interesting fact that I've
noticed
is that young women Visionaries of
Ellen's day
seem to have visions that fill the need
for example
if a baby died prematurely a young lady
May then have a vision of the baby in
heaven enjoying itself and relate this
to the mother
also Visions would occur in young women
at the request for information that the
audience was interested in
so here in Ellen's letter in the setting
of utter disappointment that Christ did
not return in 1844 and the subsequent
ridicule by those in the community
she shared a vision
she had of the of the travels of the
Avent people to the holy city
what is most interesting though is that
she wrote that this letter was not for
publication but for encouragement
and yet the editor published it anyways
but that aside let's go back to the
letter
here Ellen describes her journey into
heaven and seeing all of those who
rejected God falling off the path into
the darkness below
she writes about how God or sorry she
writes about how Jesus placed a crown on
her head and gave her a harp she saw the
144 000 and even the Tree of Life
but what we're going to focus on is when
she asked Jesus what was in the most
holy place
She Wrote
and as we were gazing at the glories of
the place referring to heaven our eyes
were attracted upward to something that
had the appearance of silver
I asked Jesus to let me see what was
within there
in a moment we were winging our way
upward and entering in
here we saw good old father Abraham
Isaac and Jacob Noah Daniel and many
liked them
and I saw a veil with a heavy Fringe of
silver and gold as a border on the
bottom
it was very beautiful
I asked Jesus what was within the Veil
he raised it with his own right arm and
bade me take heed
I saw their a glorious Ark
now miles notice that in Ellen's Vision
here Jesus only lifted one Veil and he
was already in the most holy place for
the ark rests
she didn't know she needed to describe
two veils yet to fit with Adventist
apologetics
not only that she used the term within
the veil to describe the veil covering
the location where the ark is which
causes issues with the SDA argument that
Hebrews 6 19 must mean the veil between
the courtyard and the holy place
plus when you think about it if she was
already in the STA Heavenly holy place
with candlesticks and other furniture
she would have known what was behind the
veil in front of her
so you may ask yourself why did Ellen
not mention two veils in this vision
well it's because at this time Ellen was
not a believer in the SDA theory of the
Heavenly Sanctuary yet
in fact it was only two weeks after her
vision was published
that oral Crozier published a published
a column
on the Heavenly Sanctuary message in the
day star on February 7 1846
the following year in 1847 she wrote
that crozier's Sanctuary message was
confirmed in vision
She Wrote
I believe the sanctuary to be cleansed
at the end of the 2300 days is the New
Jerusalem Temple of which Christ is a
minister
the Lord shumi envisioned more than one
year ago that brother Crozier had the
true light on the cleansing of the
sanctuary and that it was his will that
brother Crozier
should write out the view which he gave
us in the Daystar extra February 7 1846.
I feel fully authorized by the Lord to
recommend that extra to every saint
so before crozier's Day star column that
was published after her vision
she didn't know she should incorporate
the views of his column and others into
her vision
evidently the Lord passed up giving the
sanctuary message to her and instead
commissioned Crozier to break the news
two weeks later
we'll speak on this topic again very
soon but let's continue with what she
says in the arc or sorry with what she
sees in the ark
I saw there a glorious Ark overlaid with
pure gold and it had a glorious border
resembling Jesus's crowns
on it were two bright Angels their wings
were spread over the ark as they sat on
each end with their faces turned up
turned toward each other and looking
downward
now pay attention
in the ark beneath where the angel's
wings were spread was a golden pot of
Mana of a yellowish cast and I saw a rod
which Jesus said was Aaron's I saw it
Bud Blossom and bear fruit
and I saw two long golden rods on which
hung silver wires and on the wire's most
glorious grapes
one cluster was more than a man can
carry and I saw Jesus step up and take
of the Manna almonds grapes and
pomegranates
and bear them down to the city and place
them on the supper table
I stepped up to see how much was taken
away and there was just as much left and
we shouted hallelujah amen
so what's missing
anyone anyone want to guess what is
missing from the Ark of the Covenant and
Ellen's first published vision
miles do you want to guess
Ten Commandments
exactly the Ten Commandments
in heaven is teaching the Ten
Commandments are in the Ark of the
Covenant in heaven
but for some reason Ellen didn't know to
include them in the Ark in this vision
do you want another reason
it wasn't until August
well I should say this was January of
1846 and Ellen White had not been
introduced to Sabbath keeping yet
it wasn't until August of that year that
Joseph Bates published his 48-page
Sabbath pamphlet
in fact Ellen wrote in her testimonies
for the church volume 1 that in the
Autumn of 1846 we began to observe the
the Bible Sabbath and to teach and
defend it
my attention was first called to the
Sabbath when I was on a visit to New
Bedford Massachusetts earlier in the
same year
I there became acquainted with elder
Joseph Bates who had early embraced the
Avent faith and was an active
and was an active laborer in the cause
Elder Bates was keeping the Sabbath and
urged its importance
I did not feel its importance and
thought that elderbates aired in
dwelling upon the fourth Commandment
more than than upon the other nine
it's quite a bit of irony in that last
sentence as the church would later be
called The Seventh-Day Adventist and
write extensively on the Sabbath and the
Ten Commandments
but we see here it wasn't until Autumn
of 1846 that Ellen came to the
understanding that she should keep the
Sabbath
thus several months earlier in January
of the same year as we saw there was no
reason for large tablets to be in the
Ark of the Covenant in Heaven's Most
Holy place
as she stated she did not feel the
importance of the fourth Commandment
that she did not see the Ten
Commandments in the ark
to me this is what we would expect from
someone making things up
here's a timeline to recap and reinforce
these discrepancies
on the left in Orange we have her first
Vision where she only saw one Veil and
no Ten Commandments in the ark
then the sanctuary theory in green was
published Two Weeks Later by Crozier in
February of 1846 so that Ellen could be
aware of these theories
then in the Autumn of 1846 and purple
she is convinced she should keep the
Sabbath
by Bates
the following year in April of 1847 in
red she had a new vision in Topsham
Maine and it was published in her first
book on the right Christian experience
and Views in 1851.
let's now turn to this book because this
is where things get really interesting
here is Christian experience in views
from 1851.
now we will turn to page 15 and look at
the bottom right
the lord gave me the following view in
1847 while at Topsham Maine
the Brethren were assembled on the
Sabbath
we felt an unusual Spirit of prayer and
as we prayed the Holy Ghost fell upon us
we were very happy
soon I was lost to Earthly things and
was wrapped up in a vision of God's
glory
I saw an angel swiftly flying to me
he quickly carried me from the Earth to
the holy city
in the city I saw a temple which I
entered
I passed through a door before I came to
the first Veil
observe that after she was convinced of
the sanctuary message from crozier's Day
star column two weeks following her
first vision
her next vision of where the ark is
changed to reflect the doctrine with the
first and second Veil thus allowing a
different interpretation of Hebrews from
The Inspired pen
she continued
this veil was raised and I passed into
the holy place
here I saw the altar of incense the
Candlestick was seven lamps and the
table on which was the showbread after
viewing the glory of the holy Jesus
raised the second Veil and I passed into
the holy of holies
now let's see what happens or let's
let's see what appears in the ark this
time after she was convinced that the
Sabbath
in the holiest I saw an ark on the top
and sides of it was purest gold
on each end of the arc was a lovely
cheer up with their wings spread out
over it
their faces were turned toward each
other and they looked downwards
between the Angels was a golden sensor
above the ark where the angel stood was
an exceedingly bright Glory that
appeared like a throne where God dwelt
Jesus stood by the ark and as the Saints
prayers came up to Jesus
the incense in his sensor would smoke
and he offered up the prayers of the
Saints with the smoke of the incense to
his father
in the ark was the golden pot of manna
Aaron's Rod that budded and the tables
of stone which folded together like a
book
Jesus opened them and I saw the Ten
Commandments written on them with the
Finger of God
on one table was four and on the other
six
the four on the first table Shone
brighter than the other six but the
fourth the Sabbath commandment Shone
above them all
for the Sabbath was set apart to be kept
in honor of God's holy name
the holy Sabbath will glorious a Halo of
Glory was all around it
I saw that the Sabbath was not nailed to
the cross if it was the other nine
Commandments were and we are Liberty to
go forth and break them all as well as
to break the fourth
I saw that God had not changed the
Sabbath for he never changes
but the pope had changed it from the
seventh to the first day of the week for
he was to change times and laws
and I saw that if God had changed the
Sabbath from the seventh to the first
day he would have changed the writing of
the Sabbath commandment written on the
tables of stone which are now in the Ark
in the most holy place the temple in
heaven
now how did Ellen miss these tables of
stone with a glowing commandment were
the two veils in her first vision
I had to ask myself is this the behavior
we would find in a true prophet
seeing new objects in the same box shown
to you by the same Jesus from the first
vision
means that either Jesus hid the Ten
Commandments from her the first time
around like he hit the mistake in the
millerite chart
or she was generating New Visions based
on what she heard or read from others in
her community
given the amount of materials she was
taking from others and selling his light
from heaven in the future
I would say the latter
however the story doesn't end here
in the same book Christian experience
and views from 1851
a few pages earlier she actually
included her first published vision from
the Daystar
but this time around she removed the
whole section where she wrote of the
veil in the contents of the Ark as it
contradicted her new vision in the next
chapter
instead she claimed here I will give the
view that was first published in 1846.
in this view I saw only a very few of
the events of the future
more recent views have been more full I
shall therefore leave out a portion and
prevent repetition
but as we saw it wasn't frivolous
repetition that she removed she removed
the contradictions
when profits start removing or changing
what they see in their Visions based off
new convictions
a red flag should go off
so now that we've seen how Ellen learned
of the Sabbath from Bates corrected the
contents of the Ark and put a glow
around the fourth Commandment
solidifying the importance for all
Adventists growing up in the future
let's go forward two years and see how
this plays out
we will revisit the column she wrote to
the youth that we briefly saw earlier
but this time I'll I will read the whole
thing
She Wrote
those who wish to be blessed and
approved of the Lord in this world and
who expect to finally be saved and have
right to the Tree of Life must keep the
Sabbath holy
they should pray daily for grace and
wisdom to keep from polluting it in any
way
Isaiah says everyone that keepeth the
Sabbath from polluting it and taketh
hold of my Covenant even them will I
bring to my Holy Mountain
dear children are you as careful as you
should be in keeping the Sabbath
you have something to do besides laying
aside your work and Amusements on that
day
if you on that day lay plans of what you
will do when the Sabbath has passed
or talk of your work amusement and
clothes you pollute the Sabbath
the prophet has in another chapter told
us how to keep the Sabbath from
polluting it
and nothing short of doing as he has
pointed out will be keeping the Sabbath
holy
he says if thou turn away thy foot from
the Sabbath that is from treading it
down or breaking it from doing thy
pleasure on my holy day and call the
Sabbath a delight the holy of the Lord
honorable
uh the holy of the Lord honorable and
shall honor him not doing thine own ways
not finding thine own pleasure or
speaking thine own words
when you were speaking of your hope in
God of Jesus and of his soon coming and
of the beauties of the new Earth you are
not speaking your own words
of these things you may freely speak on
the Sabbath
on six days you may talk of business
matters and lay plans that are necessary
but the Sabbath is Holy time and all
worldly thoughts must on that day be
dismissed from the mind
now listen
the blessing of God will then rest upon
you and you will have the sweet
consolations of his spirit and you will
also have confidence
when you approach the throne of grace
according to the prophet it was that
identifying Mark of the remnant Church
if you do not keep the Sabbath by
putting aside all fun and conversation
that is not about God he will not bless
nor approve of you
by this understanding you should not
have confidence
when you approach the throne of grace
as she wrote the Sabbath must be kept to
finally be saved
because as you recall there is an
investigation going on in heaven to see
if you have obeyed and could be found
worthy of the benefits of his sacrifice
on the cross
miles
would you be so kind as to end us with
the gospel
and why we should have confidence now
absolutely
the gospel message Adventists
is not systematic theology
it is not every single doctrine that you
can believe in your whole system such
that it's everything that you believe
the gospel is a very specific message
it is a Transcendent message meaning it
was given by Jesus Christ himself to the
apostles
that was then pin down for us in
scripture such that that same message
that the apostles were preaching to
other people
we have today
you believe that message and that
message is the power of God unto
salvation you have to have the correct
God because it's his gospel
so this message is one about salvation
so it specifically whittled down to that
category it's not the health message
it's not what day you go to church it's
not believing the spirit of Prophecy
it's not believing the investigative
judgment it's not believing in the state
of the Dead Doctrine it's not believing
the Christian Temperance or Adventist
Temperance doctrines it's not young
Earth creationism it's not calling
people to leave protestantism none of
that stuff is the gospel the gospel is
not an end times message for a present
truth time for a specific people at the
end of time that's a different message
so it's a specific message about
salvation
and by believing that you're saved it is
a simple message what we see the
apostles preaching one example the
Philippian Jailer
hears about his need for a savior what
must I do to be saved
the apostles didn't launch into this
well do you have two weeks for a Daniel
seminar
and to talk about the seven steps of the
sanctuary and you know the labor and and
Jesus is at step five of the judgment
and then there's going to be the
executive judgment none of that stuff
none of that stuff
believe on the Lord Jesus Christ and you
will be saved now I know Adventists will
hear that and think so all you're saying
is someone has to check mental boxes no
let me explain what's being said there
belief is when a person truly has a
heartfelt Trust
it's not just merely mental the devil
has the mental box checked he knows that
Jesus Christ exists that's not what
we're saying
we're saying when a person realizes the
standard is perfection it's not Jesus
came to to open the door to make it a
possibility to now have a do-over of the
law
and that by confessing and transferring
your sins to the Heavenly sanctuary and
trying your best you can then be found
worthy of the atoning benefits of
Christ's sacrifice in cooperation with
Jesus's gradually infused righteousness
to you
that's not what's going on at all
the standard is you break the law once
you're doomed
that's it there is no do-over
a little bit of a plug two weeks from
today or not from today but in two weeks
the video for that week
is about this specific topic so stand by
for more on that but the law is clear
you break it once there's no Provisions
for forgiveness there's no Provisions
for do-overs
you're condemned and the bad news
Adventists or all of us not just
Adventists is that you've broken it
so it doesn't matter now that that you
say well Jesus gives us a second chance
at that and we can be empowered now by
the power of the Holy Spirit no that's
not the way it works
you have to have a a righteousness that
fulfills that demand and requirement
only Jesus has that to give
so the good news is that despite the
fact that you have broken the law of God
and there's nothing that you can do
alongside God or cooperation or any sort
of obedience to remedy that Jesus can
Jesus has the ability to not gradually
impart to you righteousness bit by bit
based on your cooperation but in full he
can pay the debt that you owe in
incomplete so the good news is is that
despite being a sinner God is both the
just and the justifier he doesn't let
sin slide such that he's unjust he
punished it in the person of Jesus
Christ
while at the same time demonstrates his
great mercy and Grace on vessels that
are unworthy Sinners and can do so
justly by giving that person the
righteousness of Jesus Christ and it's
by believing that Jesus was who he says
he was he's alive right now we're not
saying he's he's a figment of
imagination no he's alive right now he's
on a real throne ruling and reigning
mediating on behalf of his people
so we're not saying that he's some
figment or it's some just well you think
he's like a spirit or no no no no he's
real he's alive he literally physically
raised out of the Grave on the third day
a person that believes on that trust in
that
trust that Jesus is who he says he is
believing on the person and work of
Jesus that person will find that he is a
perfect savior there's no investigation
that doesn't mean that there won't be
obedience
we're talking about how a person is
reconciled and made right with God it's
in the person and and work of Jesus
Christ Alone faith alone in Christ alone
once a person does that God changes the
person they are raised to spiritual
newness of Life they are born again they
are Titus 3 5 they are the washing of
regeneration uh Second Corinthians 5 17
they're made a new creature in Jesus
Christ these terms of in Christ in him
that you see in scripture those are
terms of Union with Christ it's about
the new identity that a person has when
they're taken from the kingdom of
darkness into the Kingdom of Light that
happens when a person believes and
trusts on the Lord Jesus Christ and yes
he will change you yes obedience will
follow in that yes you'll have new
desires all of that stuff that doesn't
then supplement or maintain your
righteous standing with God because God
doesn't disown his children
Hebrews chapter 12 God chastises his
children he's a good parent it's not
um he's investigating to see well is
this person really no there's none of
that going on God will chastise you if
you're his he'll chastise you and he'll
correct you and get you back into shape
and yes all of those things that I know
the Adventist Church loves to disparage
if you disagree with them and say well
you're you're against obedience you're
just no I'm not saying that at all I'm
saying that the gospel the good news is
what must I do to be saved believe on
the Lord Jesus Christ trust in him today
the second person of the godhead entered
into his own creation as the suffering
servant foretold of by the prophets of
old he came he died he lived a perfect
sinless life he was was crucified died
and buried raised on the third day for
our justification and all of those that
place their faith in him will find that
he is a perfect savior that's the gospel
it's not your belief about all these
other points of of systematic theology
which I'm a theology nerd folks I love
theology but those things outside of
that are not the gospel that's the point
doesn't mean they're not important
doesn't mean the Bible doesn't talk
about them but that message is what
transcends things like denominations my
brother here tonight that just gave a
presentation Adventist
he doesn't align with me on every aspect
of systematic theology that's irrelevant
he's still my brother because there's
something that transcends those sorts of
things I don't need to know what he
believes about creation I don't need to
know what he believes about should there
be drums in worship service I don't need
to know if he what he believes about do
you believe in Presbyterian form of
government or church autonomy like a
Baptist that doesn't have anything to do
with what unite him and I and make him
and I Brothers we want that for you
that's why we did what we did tonight
it's not to dunk on the Adventist Church
it's not to say oh look how wrong they
are that's not the purpose that's not
why this platform exists folks it's not
to dunk on Seventh adventism
the Adventist Church it loves to say oh
they're angry or they're no folks
I have far better things and so does
this brother I know he does
far better things to be doing if that
was the case I don't the amount of time
folks that it takes to do something like
this
it just it doesn't match up with with
the reality we care about you we want
you to know the truth we want you to
come to know the true Christ and his
gospel because this gospel folks is
undefeated
it's undefeated
there have been I mean communism's tried
secularism's tried atheism has tried
adventism's tried
arianism tried I mean the Rome tried
Islam has tried this gospel is
undefeated because this is the true
gospel and this gospel actually changes
people
like he was talking about tonight I
haven't made my testimony video I need
to at some point I know I keep saying
I'm going to do that folks and I will I
just want to give it the proper time
that it needs but all of that to say we
want you to come to know this don't be
afraid God calls us some people were
talking about this in the chat a little
bit earlier God calls us to use our
reasoning faculties not live with your
head in the sand you're called to
glorify God with your mind as well not
just your physical actions your mind
that includes thinking critically
rationally logically not to get super
deep but those sorts of things logic
reason rationality those things are not
arbitrary those things are a reflection
of God himself this gets into thinking
God's thoughts after him
um it gets deep but all that to say God
wants us to think critically God wants
us to ask questions and it's okay to ask
questions you're not going to get in
trouble for asking questions you're not
going to uh anger God by asking
questions it's glorifying God to think
and reason through things and and war
with things and question things so all
of that to say brother that is
essentially the gospel the person in
work of Jesus Christ faith in in that
and trusting in Him and He will uh be
enough he is enough
um and the the call is to keep our eyes
fixed on him Christians need the gospel
daily that's not something it's a one
and done I got my ticket punch thing uh
we need to remind it of the Gospel daily
because
um apart from Christ we have nothing to
bring to the table no amount of
obedience no amount of anything can add
to what Christ did and again I'll say it
just because I know it is such a drum
that they beat we're not disparaging
obedience okay
we're not disparaging a b it's we're
simply saying the only way a person is
reconciled to God Is by what Christ has
done you can't add anything to it Ellen
White taught your reconciled to God by
faith plus obedience to the law no ain't
wrong no law gospel distinction and
again in two weeks that's what the uh
the video on the channel the the net new
piece of content will be so I'll save
the rest for that brother thank you so
much for being here
let people know anything else that you
would like to share you are tagged in
the title as well as the description box
folks go and check his channel out he
doesn't have a lot of content but he has
quality content so 100 I'm sure you're
gonna have more content coming out soon
let people know anything else that you'd
like to share
um and then I will let you go and I will
do uh my sign off for the night
yeah uh thanks for having me on and uh
bearing with my my voice uh it's been
hoarse lately so I've been struggling
tonight thank you no absolutely
I do want to acknowledge and thank those
Anonymous colleagues who have
contributed to the parallel examples
from other authors found in in this
presentation and and those to come
we owe them a lot for their hard and
tedious work of finding where Ellen took
her information from
because you will find very few examples
on Adventist apologists websites and for
good reason
so please thank these individuals that
have that have gone beyond Walter Ray
for their time and dedication in the
comments
with that said I encourage everyone to
keep learning thinking reading your
Bible and basking in the wonderful glory
of the Gospel good night amen brother
again thank you so much for being here
um you're typically in the the chat so
it was nice to actually have you here
um In the Flesh so to speak and to share
your breadth of knowledge with us so
again thank you so much for that
all right folks so
that was excellent
um it's always nice like I said when I'm
not the one doing all the Talking
um I love that brother I'm so grateful
for God's provision in his life I'm not
going to get into any sort of personal
details or anything like that but
um
what what a what a gift what a blessing
what a testimony I love that everyone's
testimony out of adventism is different
I love that unlike in adventism where
everyone's expected to be a carbon copy
of what Ellen White claimed Jesus's
personality was
um God makes people differently
test the profit is not a fire brand like
answering adventism and not everyone
needs to be that way
um I get really worked up typically
especially on live streams
um I'm self-aware of that by the way
folks
um but that's because I'm passionate
about this I'm committed to this folks
full time
full time we have a team of people that
are dedicated to this
this isn't just an ax to grind
we're making a difference
this platform is making a difference
we're approaching the one year
anniversary of answering adventism what
a year
and we're just getting started
we are just getting the engine going
folks buckle up
you can go watch the live streams from
almost a year ago you can go watch the
content for almost a year ago I've been
saying this
week in and week out buckle up it's
gonna be a long journey this is a
marathon not a Sprint
we've got a lot of stuff to cover folks
we've got a lot of people to talk to
we're going to bring some Heavy Hitters
on here
this is going to make a difference
if you're an Adventist leader
we're going to make a difference okay
the days of old are over
Ray
Ford
they laid the foundation
we're launching off that Foundation
you're not going to deceive people any
longer
this gospel is undefeated
you can't stop it
it's not because of me it's not because
I test the profit it's because this
gospel is Jesus Christ gospel
his kingdom is growing it's expanding
there's nothing you guys can do to stop
it
because all of Christ's enemies are
going to be made his footstool
the Adventist Church not the people
folks the Adventist Church the
organization
it is an enemy of the Lord Jesus
and all Christ has to do to defeat this
enemy
he owns the clock
just keep doing what he's been doing
the time is going to run out on this
movement
I long for the day that answering
adventism folks doesn't have to exist
I'd love to turn the lights off and shut
it down tomorrow
but as long as this organization is up
and Ticking
answering adventism is going to be up
in a few weeks
we're going out and recording our first
boots on the ground content
we got a lot of stuff in store folks
we're talking the answering adventism
conference I mean I don't want to get
ahead of things here
but just understand
we're going to make a difference
God has a people
some of them are caught up in this
organization just like we were
and we're going to be a lifeline
also to the Adventist leadership
we're going to be a voice for all the
people that you have have spiritually
disenfranchised and left spiritually
orphaned and then lied about and said oh
they left because they were emotionally
hurt
nah not gonna happen
not gonna happen
those people haven't had a voice
folks I worked on testimonies yesterday
to get our our Instagrams up and going
now we're going to start sharing these
tests it just I had tears in my eyes at
some of these
all these people no one's ever heard
anything no one reached out to them cold
shoulder from from the SDA Church
well hold up well why is that happening
all of a sudden oh because they're
asking questions they're not supposed to
and then lied about
like no it's not gonna happen anymore
it's not going to happen anymore we're
gonna be a voice for some of these
people I want to look at a couple things
here he talked about
the overall thesis of this being
was Ellen White who she
claimed to be
notice what she says here folks
this is from selected messages book
three
look what she says here
under relation of the vision to writing
and practice
she's talking about herself here
and here I would state that although I'm
as dependent upon the spirit of the Lord
in writing My Views as I am in receiving
them yet the words I employ in
describing what I have seen are my own
unless they be those spoken to me by an
Angel which I always enclose in marks of
quotation close quote
but hold up remember that quote test the
profit brought up we've looked at that
one before
God gave her the words
oh no it's thought inspiration that's
another area where things
shifted
but nevertheless
no they weren't always her words
furthermore
this is her responding to other
movements of the day
who were coming up against the
legitimacy of the Advent movement who
had their own prophets supposedly so
Ellen had to obviously dispel that
those efforts
look what she says here
so she well first she says the Lord's
not given you a message to call the
Seventh Adventist Babylon and to call
the people of God to come out of her so
see the charge was being made against
them that well no the Adventist Church
is Babylon
all the reasons you may present cannot
have weight with me on this subject
because the Lord has given me decided
light that is that is opposed to such a
message
I do not doubt that your sincerity or
honesty she's writing to somebody here
who's asking about these things I have
written long letters at different times
to those who were accusing the Church of
Seventh-Day Adventists of being Babylon
that they were not handling the truth
you think individuals have prejudiced my
mind
if I am in this state
I am not fitted to be entrusted with the
work of God
but this matter has been brought before
my mind in other cases where individuals
have claimed to have messages for the
Seventh Adventist Church of a similar
character and the word has been given me
but leave them not I have not sent them
and yet they ran close quote notice the
end there in quotations that's
supposedly from the angel like she just
said in the last quote
her mind was never prejudiced by others
if so she wasn't fit
for the role of profit
or the work that that God had out for
her which entailed more than a prophet
she said
no
avenus
you can't have adventism without Ellen
White I know that you want to do the
Adventist light thing
you're on the path that we all followed
it's only a matter of time
before you have to accept the facts
you can't have adventism without Ellen
White not if you actually care about
being consistent
the people that oftentimes get labeled
as the Fanatics the over-the-top yada
yada
well sorry folks but those people tend
to actually understand Seventh-day
Adventist systematic theology
they understand how all this stuff is
connected and how if you remove
something like that the whole structure
Falls
this idea of oh well
adventism's a big tent and no this is
your rebranding effort like the Mormon
church is in right now because you're
always influenced by culture just like
you were in the 50s and 60s when all the
racism stuff was going rampant just like
it was with the Mormons
and you had to Pivot oh in science
because science all of a sudden was like
irk no that's not what's going on
you always have to Pivot with well
that's what we see right now
the Adventist Church is some people
within the Adventist Church are trying
to do this whole pivot thing now where
it's like oh well we're just like
evangelicals but we go to church on
Saturday you're my brother you know
we're all one big family
no
no doesn't work that way
an Adventist Christ calls you to follow
him wherever he leads despite the cause
do you really believe it
when the going gets tough that's when
our faith is truly tested
Jesus says people will have to sacrifice
things that includes your comfort in the
Adventist world
it includes because you know you know
deep down well if I do this people are
going to not talk to me anymore I'll
lose friends yep all of us did
but Christ is worth it
Christ is worth
next week folks we're going to be
responding to
Walter Veith
we've been getting a lot of requests for
this and I gotta be honest folks you
guys have to understand the torture
that some of us go through to prepare
for these things it's not just like oh I
just sit down and wipe the sleep out of
my eyes and turn the camera on and all
right well now
no I wish it were that easy I wish it
were that easy
but when you're when we're doing these
three four hour presentations that takes
a lot of time
I have to listen to these things over
and over and over again
so please understand the delay around
this has been
um the fact that that sort of stuff has
to take place to respond to these things
but I know a lot of you have been
waiting for us addressing Vice for those
that do not know he is the equivalent of
say The Alex Jones of adventism
um newspaper theology 101
um
we'll we'll leave it at that we'll be
responding to him finally next week
um and just some just some of the crazy
stuff man that that these people say
that
you hear Adventists then regurgitate and
it just
it's not gonna fly anymore Adventist
leaders it's not gonna fly anymore
you're the model worked before
changing the game we're changing the
game
Google ads boots on the ground we got
people contacting us that want to be
partnered and involved in this
internationally
bro folks we broke 300 000 website views
in the last month
so to all the Adventist apologists and
the critics
who all say oh you're just you're just
like the rest of them you're no
different than okay
okay
I said and have been saying for a whole
year
it's going to be a rough year for this
movement
and we're just getting started
we're committed to this
we're going to pull people or pray to be
used by God rather
to help pull people from the trenches
because this movement is leading to the
damnation of millions of people
it's not just another denomination
we're getting into that on Monday
with some help from our good friend Doug
Batchelor
it's not just another denomination
it's time to make a choice Adventists
the call from the Adventist Church to us
has always been
um
come out of her my people
and so on this platform we have embraced
that
and we're going to say it back to you
all
you need to come out of her
if you are one of the sheep and you hear
the shepherd's voice do not Harden your
heart
tomorrow's not promised folks I could
die tonight I could die tomorrow
and being ready for that is not making
sure that your diet is in the best place
it's not making sure that I go to church
last Saturday
it's not do I believe the investigative
judgment have do I remember every sin
that I need to confess and have a
folks you are looking to yourself you're
not looking to the Lord Jesus when
that's your mindset
I'm prepared
I just had an Adventist commenting this
past week it's just crazy things they
say
you're going to be running for the hills
when Jesus returns Mike all I said back
was why
why
because youth because that lady thinks
to be prepared for the second coming
there's all these things
no I'm hidden in Christ Jesus
I'm seated with Christ in the heavenlies
I'm United to Jesus Christ by faith
that is signed and sealed to me every
week when I meet the Lord Jesus at his
table and I'm reminded of the good news
of the Gospel as it's proclaimed over a
local extension of his body and I'm able
to commune with him and be reminded of
that and partake of the Lord every week
I'm ready
Adventist you can be ready too
you can be ready too
and it's by trusting in Christ
by the day you go to church not by your
diet not by the investigative judgment
The Three Angels message is some present
truth no
Philippian Jailer what must I do to be
saved believe on the Lord Jesus Christ
you'll be saved Christ is enough you can
be prepared so come out of her my people
until then until next time God bless
[Music]